Wow E great mov hello everybody it is
Friday a beautiful
Friday I'll tell you why because today
is our beautiful boys uh birthday Bru's
birthday he turned two
today what do they say when you turn the
number that the day is isn't their name
for that golden birthday golden golden
birthday big news oh boy you won't
remember it
shame so uh but anyway the reason I
actually say that other than to uh pay
honor to my beautiful son is that we're
going to leave at 4: cuz I want to spend
time with our
boy we got a really cool present and um
cupcakes and stuff that I want to we got
them my kitchen set it's so cool like a
little mini kitchen so cute yeah they'll
love that uh um so that's what so I'm
going to try to cram we're going to cram
today we're going to ducky has something
in his mouth but I don't know he's
already unidentify object in my thank
you to Shopify wow we love Shopify sure
do you sure do they're the best thank
you for your support quick shout out to
Teddy fresh today we are um beginning a
new method of release where we'll be
doing instead of dropping the whole
collection at one time we will be
releasing
them we'll be releasing them I guess
like slowly throughout the month yes
sometimes it will be one item like today
we released this blanket which I'm
shocked to find out that it's already
sold out I know I didn't get to talk
about it it's it is really cool though
check out this throw blanket so sick
actually that is cool uh thank you and
you can't have it it's out of stop my
well right it's sold out so if you guys
want to stay on top make sure to follow
us on social medias and stuff yes so
some you can get a jump on it if there's
a group of items that kind of go
together like a jacket and pant that's a
set or something like that it'll be
released in one day um and there may be
like a couple day break or one day break
but it's almost going to be like an
everyday release throughout the week and
you know what it's better for a lot of
reasons but one of them is like it's
really can be complicated and a pain
when you're waiting for a few straggling
pieces you know and it's like you can
release them as they come
mhm and also I feel like sometimes um
I've I see it a lot in my personal life
where people will see me wear something
Teddy fresh and they're like oh when is
it coming out and I'll be like it's
already out um it's just when the whole
collection comes out at once I think
it's easy to like Miss stuff or it's
hard for us to get to talk about
everything and really show everything
yeah so we want to try this new approach
so we can give each item its own Focus
right so there it is Teddy fresh.com
follow us on social media and great and
great throw
[Applause]
[Music]
blanket
all
right okay good idea so anyway
um I don't know how much I just cut out
probably most of
it as I was saying my friend sent me
this article this
morning he says hey dude saw this crab
Under My article on Tech times hope you
are okay Ryan kavana wi slap motion
Ethan Klein loses with damage
potentially in the millions and then I
said is it sponsored it's on this web
page uh [__] what was it like Tech
something it's one of these websites
where you just essentially pay people to
write articles I'm not saying he did
that right but there are a lot of that
on that website like if he was going to
do it it would be on that web be onsite
like that yeah
um but he's dude come on
man
why does he keep saying he won thank you
bro you did not win
[__] you [__] I need the max win well
he did he he did win the slot motion
just a motion he keeps blurring the line
right so a slap motion is essentially a
motion to dismiss right based on this uh
particular clause about it being really
hard to defame public figures and a lot
of times people in public figures who
have a lot of money use lawsuits to
silence their critics and so this
attempts to cut that that uh that
function yeah yeah stop that from so we
filed the anti slap and the first judge
uh denied it but that's again that's
not that has no bearing on the actual
defamation Clause it has nothing to do
with that but the the ruling that the
judge gave was pretty in my
opinion had a lot of problems which is
why on appeal we're feeling very
confident that we're going to win it
feeling very confident are you going to
publish an article in Tech times I
should you actually should that would be
pretty funny I got to do it on all those
websites Ethan Klein destroys Ryan
kavanau Ryan kavanau for good so
trillions in Damages you got to get it
so you know like when you search
somebody's name on uh on Google and it
just has like the top like Artic like
recent news about that you need like a
grid of like eight stories so good Ryan
Kavanaugh for someone that AR irrelevant
dude if when this stuff is over and I
hope it ends with us winning it's going
to be Gang Busters like he can't do [__]
dude I want to go crazy with that CU
there's website where you you give them
an like an article and they just post it
on their whole [__] system that's it
that's it 100 we yeah yeah yeah yeah so
yeah that's a service I'm interested in
I know all about
that I need the max win I mean we don't
have to win necessarily do we need the
max I need the max we I mean I won the
torous interference one that could be
that's that's article worthy yeah
congratulations and then Ryan Kavanaugh
tried to shut down our website that's
article let's look into that yeah yeah
we I don't have to look into it we'll
talk okay we'll talk and not and by the
way not to post anything
defamatory only only to spread news
about something that's really important
in popular culture yeah I mean look I
started in hollyood when I was pretty
young I think I was running the studio
when I was 25 how I was arguably called
the most powerful person in Hollywood
for about 10
years a year and 20 TV shows all right
Ryan come on man dude nobody cares
you're you're angry you're
bankrupt so um we had a lot of fun
watching his uh podcast on Patriot
TV um on
Wednesday however the main course as
it's been described to me the failure
podcast episode one is still on the menu
my friends and I'm very excited to
review that today with you guys we
eating we are eating we are eating good
baby so uh that's going to be what I
want to get into here in the
meantime let me look at this article
actually I'm curious here's Tech
times let's see te times this is this is
one that we've actually we've looked at
before Oh we have yeah yeah
last oh this from last year yeah yeah I
it's still funny that you have people in
your life just randomly stumbling upon
yeah how did you stumble upon I wonder
if this is like a hi trffic article
because of our fans or maybe somebody's
driving traffic to it maybe or someone's
paying for it to be promoted but don't
they have to that would be yeah somebody
perhaps would be plugging it with
boosting it with some money perhaps
maybe allegedly brought before the court
what is referred to as anti-ap motion
which in cases like these are usually
granted slap stand by the way the judge
who denied it apparently
like you said it was an anomaly judge
who re like never given anti slaps like
he's given like 90% no you got a bad
dice roll on that one it sounds which is
fine that's the judicial system is set
up for that and that's why when you go
to an Appel at court there's three very
experienced judges right who together
make a decision yeah which is why I
believe they will make the right
decision that's right do the right thing
do the right thing judges we love the
judges of America though we love them
all I need the max win yeah California
actually has the strongest anti-s slap
of the whole nation I think probably
just because the the in the
entertainment industry is Will Smith
just smack the [__] out of me so
intimately
tied um it has one of the strongest
anti-s slap stances with over 90% oh so
that's what he was saying yeah 90%
granted
but we'll see just the facts just the
facts Jack the facts facts this
[__] said this could possibly
become one of the most landmarked cases
of his type since Hulk Hogan's case in
2016 against Gawker where Hulk won 140
million in Damages Hulk Hogan with a
[__] what the [__] bro why sto there um
you know Fox News had to pay like a
billion dollars or like $300 million to
um what was the name of that uh uh oh
God damn it Dominion Dominion also the
circumstances of the Hulk Hogan thing
was a little different what posting his
nudes yeah like posting his porn videos
without permission G to bang HK [__]
what did I I believe I just read the
headline of a Variety article but okay
great very
exciting well he is one of the uh most
powerful producers of our
time um so in the meantime we've
got Ben Shapiro is his song really
charting at number one still fishizzle
so I yeah it is but why well it's the
number one song on iTunes well that's
not meaningless well as an apple Fanboy
I didn't know iTunes was still around
yeah when was the last time that you've
uh used iTunes isn't that what you
people listen to No they use apple music
Apple music there's no more iTunes on
Mac computers there's 's a tab inside
Apple music that says iTunes store and
he's number one in that so these are
people that are buying the song Hold on
they why do they have different lists
why would Apple have two different lists
because take a look in the dock the next
link right under the one that you
clicked that's the app this is the
actual wait what the hell hold on hold
the phone hold the phone so here's the
actual Apple 100 yeah and you will find
that Ben is not on well hold on let me
contrl
F5 it's not there Ben boy Ben and
Jerry you're not even in the top hundred
dude no which of course he isn't but
yeah uh I so what does this mean the
Boomers that watch Daily wire I guess
still buy MP3s on iTunes occasionally
and that was enough to that is pretty
funny that is that is funed indeed so
this is thank you man this is people
without a music subscription that just
wanted to drop 99 cents to own the track
correct nice right
Legends okay well congratulations to Ben
for being on iTunes top indeed indeed
apparently he sold only a hundred of
them and he's number one well well said
good stuff all right Ben I don't need
you to Parrot everything I
say um anyway here he is bragging about
his uh rap career uh he's had a lot to
say about it let's take a
look oh God it's kind of funny I'm not
even going to I'm not going to admit
like it's not funny he's out here with
chains one of the top comments is if
it's anyone else this would be Charming
stick but boy hatred of rap and black
people in general is well documented
yeah I mean the guy when he does it it
feels like
blackface the guy famously said rap
isn't real music and anyone that thinks
so is like an idiot so it's like it it
obviously and openly is you know
trashing on it so the culture well okay
that's a good point that's a good point
we hate Ben chiro here don't we folks su
su su I mean it's funny that he's
embarrassing himself like that don't get
me wrong I'm not going to say it's not
funny this video it's good stick
yeah does he hate black people probably
indeed indeed all you folks have been
sticking around for my Ben do you hate
black people yes or
no indeed he does okay W he does hate
them it's weird cut and dry do you hate
is black people your favorite category
uh ethnic category or I doubt that I
think there's one more about black
people for him albar death to America oh
you think the the Muslims are his least
favorite no actually death Jews death to
Israel are specifically Arabs or yeah
Arabs yeah he says we bathe in sewage
okay do you hate that was crazy he did
have some
crazy what did he say we got a he said
some really wild [__] man yeah let me
find okay Ben do you hate black people
or Arabs more if you had to
decide indeed indeed I'm sorry not both
I think he said both not bathe in sewage
Arabs like to bomb crap and live in open
sewage they they don't bathe in sewage
they just live in open they love to live
in more s at least CU I was going to say
bathing in sewage isn't really bathing
right right right counterproductive did
you know that the verbage did you know
that in Egypt the canals there are not
full with water but just tons of sewage
and then they swim in it it's it's
Recreation time it's Savage it's
crazy all right go ahead it seems made
up see yeah that seems made up how do
you get so much [__] how can you get so
much [__] it's really well cuz I think
Islam may be the only religion where
you're supposed technically you're
supposed to like wash yourself off five
times a day before you pray of course
five times a day yeah before you pray
you're supposed to you're not supposed
to take a full bath but you're supposed
to like wash your hands your arms five
times with soap yeah that seems like it
would dry your [__] out every day I
guess I don't know not
everyone I'm concerned for my for my
Muslim brothers and sisters out there
not everyone uses soap I'm not sure
about the soap aspect yeah just as long
as you you moisturize after Jews do that
too you know that but but the Jewish Uh
custom is really light they just take a
bucket of water and pour it over the
hand so it's like symbolic okay it's not
really like getting with some soap and
get ready for surgery type of [__] death
to the
jewy Ben my my aunt's the one that kind
of taught us and she kind of has a
cleaning phobia so I don't know if
that's part of it or that was just
little extra ingredient she added yeah
interesting the the soap part but the
actual cleaning up oh the new thumbnail
camera made is really good you like it
did you update it uh I did although it's
still showing me the old one sometimes
this happens while we're live it it's
updated I think it's updated yeah today
we're closing the book on on well let me
go ahead Ben I barely got even got into
this should take it away hip hop talk
because after all I am America's number
one hipop artist Dr Dr
benm jpac Ben with the
benjies that's right
fishizzle that was racist yeah see what
I mean it's just like fishizzle he that
was racist bad coming from
him say that again dare this stick was
old in the '90s of like white white you
know stiff guy pretending to be a rapper
but Ben say one more time fishizzle okay
just say the n-word already I mean come
on jpac can I say that is that funny I
mean you guys didn't Buton it I'm saying
Ben wants to say the n-word so bad just
do it brother indeed you don't need to
do all this for shizel and all this well
well
said talk I'm kidding you know f about
the number one song in America according
to iTunes and that is fact my boy Tom
McDonald I'll admit my boy Tom did most
of that straight up do you know who uh
Old McDonald had a farm it's about Tom
he's so white trash the dude is he's Old
McDonald he is
old fishizzle F heavy lifting on this
song but I was present and indeed I did
rap and um I've contended before that if
you can speak
look like he's at a bar mitz I'm still
not convinced
yeah that's the pitfall of this having
the statue of a 13-year-old boy I mean
he looks like it he looks like he just
[__] he's on Dance Floor listening to
LMFAO or some [__] then definitely tore
his Torah portion up like he blasted
that [__] oh he crushed that yeah he
crushed
that how did this is meritocracy right
here you all did that right yeah I did
my Torah portion did you crush it um I
got through it you got through it the
thing is like I explained to Eli it's
different in America because you you
have to memorize like pages and pages of
words in a language you don't understand
at all yeah like you just read it and
that's easy I cheated you cheated I had
the phonetics like in front of me oh
dude does it count I don't know dude are
you still a boy maybe oh I wish they let
me do that do you know how stressful it
was trying to prepare for that [__] it
was it was pretty it was pretty brutal
and like um but yeah the Fs in front of
me sh man what I don't know it's all
fragmented in my mind will our boys be
baritz
food I don't know I could I could take
it or leave it honestly honestly we both
of us don't really care about all that
stuff so yeah I'm not super into it
matter to me I don't like the whole cuz
the thing is when you go to Temple like
that there's mad religious
indoctrination yeah I just I don't I
don't Vibe with
the with the Vibes I don't Vibe with the
Vibes if if he was like if one of our
sons was like I want to do a bar mitzvah
because all I'm I care about Judaism for
some reason I'd say all right let's go I
mean I don't know maybe he you know yeah
I guess you don't you never know be I'm
not going to discourage him but yeah I
can't imagine a young boy choosing to do
that like all of us were like I this is
the worst this is the worst year of our
life I remember I didn't have a choice
I'm sure he's just going to care about
what we're buying him for his birthday I
I agree that that's probably yeah all
right so anyway congratulations to Ben
for being number one on iTunes with 100
sales and so I present to you without
any further Ado the number one doing
well it's number one on iTunes but
iTunes is not the real chart the real
chart is Apple music iTunes is for
Boomers that buy a track for 99 so I
presume he must have sold like at least
75 song in
America
facts cuz Okay that was confusing me
because I like there's no way any actual
fan of music is listening to this song
There's no way yeah even if you're a
bench PE fan you're not listening to
that song simps and the weird Boomers
that eat the [__] up on Facebook or
whatever true probably crushed on
Facebook facts
uh Pooky petition for Ethan to recreate
iconic Pooky Tik Tok yeah somebody at
work was telling me the same thing dude
this is okay I don't know anything about
these people I love them but this is the
worst thing I hated everything about it
it's so boud are they big creators they
are now I don't know how big they were
before but this is like a very popular
Trend this is their thing her their last
name is [__]
it oh Pucket I thought like pH I no
there's just a p Pucket I thought it was
Pucket cample hunt Pucket and her
husband jet his name is
jet that's it bro that's all you need to
know about this dude his name is jet
it's like the F fell off the top
Jeff that's a name
jet J TT he went viral for their outfit
of the day video here it is it has over
6 million views love that
in the video jet calls his wife
Pooky let's go almost
at now date night taking Pooky to a new
spot tonight with three other couples
and puky looks absolutely amazing good
Lord babe I love the old black thank you
I'm wearing my Kelly I'm so excited and
then I have on girlfriend denim revolve
little lace top revolve sweater and JLo
heels I'm wearing a late Christmas
present from Campbell Jack is gutteridge
shirt gutteridge also it's store out of
Italy her's belt PA jeans as always I
was like wait what what is always the P
the pants hold on as always and all
right for everybody that follows his
fashion tips you know what it is ostrich
L tonight damn somehow it seems like
he's wearing an expensive outfit
according to what he said but it does
not look expensive her bag is like
$30,000 and paig jeans are pretty
expensive too they make a good jeans but
they are expensive so there's like a
shoehorn effect
where if you spend a lot of money on
clothes they're nice but then there's
another tier of of pricing for people
that are so rich they don't even like
care at all and then you end up spending
like 10 10 20 $30,000 on a jacket just
because you feel the need just because
you feel that you H you have to do that
that's like old money fashion yeah like
what he's wearing that's like old
Southern old money stuff MH so what ends
up happening is the shoehorn effect is
that they come back around and then look
like they bought it at
Costco like it doesn't fit him well it
just it looks corny it's too long why is
it so long the jacket looks like [__] on
him it just it doesn't look I mean but I
like that he's sing for his wife he
loves his wife and that's is that a
Birkin she's caring yes okay that's
that's my level money that's why I was
saying it's like $30,000 probably and
she said Revolt is that an expensive
brand revolve is like they have
expensive stuff and cheaper stuff it's
kind of they carry all kinds so okay I
don't know
fire fire I love them uh unfortunately
it was just found out I just read this
right now uh she had apologized for
resurface photos she made no not the
Parabellum
balls it probably was that was okay what
happened uh olding
Anum
godamn it it was
Anabell bro every person from the south
no offense Sam but it seems like every
other person how about that from the
south has participated in these crazy
ANTM Bellum balls which is like themed
of like plant back on the plantation oh
and apparently it's pretty normal there
I think a lot of people like I don't
know if they happen that much anymore
but like 20 years ago it was totally
normal for people to have these parties
and I think a lot of the people there
maybe didn't understand the context of
it just to give him CU you know just to
give him a little bit of benefit of the
doubt but now anyone who's going viral
that's what happened to um the guy who
got fired
from from from Bachelor bachor right
yeah he got fired for defending someone
who went to a Parabellum ball he didn't
even go ant Bellum antibellum antibellum
wasn't it the girl he The Bachelor ended
up
choosing they're still together and
they're still together because oh yeah
so The Bachelor was a black dude and the
girl he chose is a white Southern Girl
and then it came out towards the end of
the show that she's been doing these
antibellum balls and it turned into a
pretty big but they're they're still
together so they broke up I think for
the Optics of it but I mean it's been
like two or three years and they're
still together so I'm not going to hate
on that there you go making it work yeah
um I noticed someone in chat say it's
big in southern Greek life and that is
true
um it's something that like sororities
do especially like in south Georgia
where she went to college she went to
college in south Georgia um they do like
antibellum themed or like it's mostly
like the fashion I guess that they not
defending it at all but yeah that's they
dress like the the misses did back on
Plantation day well didn't that band
lady anab Bellum they had to change
their name right they're go by like lady
a now lady a we know what that a stands
for yeah so wait what happened at ANM
Bell and ball really what happened I
think it's just a it's just a party
that's themed like an old old time it's
like a costume party but then that
doesn't sound that bad if it's just a c
except the C the thing that you're
dressing up as is slave slave
owner but no there was a specific
fashion sense during that time not just
you know what I me the photos of her she
was in front of a Confederate flag
that's bad okay well that that's
different okay see that's what I'm
wonder they must be doing more than that
like if they must be having Confederate
flags and [__] like that sure yeah cuz
then then you're like oh yeah this is
about slavery right cuz otherwise it's
just essentially it's just like
Victorian era party yeah exactly exactly
okay so there yeah so here's here's her
apology Mrs Pucket as some of you have
seen some some old photos of mine
recently resurfaced do we have those I
have come on down to the an Bell and
ball I'll tell you the South will ride
brother the Dixie will never fall God
Long Live that Confederacy
boy and I'll tell you this it's not
about state
rights it's about slavery we're fighting
for
slavery um she continues at the time
these photos were taken I was 20 I
didn't fully understand the impact of my
actions the way I do now 12 years later
I fully apologize for the harm this may
have caused for some and take full
responsibility jet kn I love sharing our
lives with you all and getting to know
our community on such an intimate level
sounds like maybe too
intimate because we live our lives so
publicly everything is on the internet
even my mistakes we hope to continue to
bring you with us on our journey as we
continue to learn and grow
honestly I think that's a that's a good
apology I mean she did it when she was
20 and
hasn't he being
[Music]
tethered
yeah um I she did this when she was 20
and hasn't like done any Confederate
parties since I think that's a fair
apology
right yeah she's
good just don't I'll tell you what man
just don't let me see that Confederate
flag fly no
more
mhm um that's exciting oh God this is
okay this is the photo I believe there
must be more this is the only one I
found so far but because the article
mentions one of her in front of a
Confederate flag I'm guessing there's
more yeah this it has to be cuz this is
just like I
said doesn't mean anything
really so there wasn't a Confederate
flag in one of the photos or is there
other sounds like yes there it sounds
like there's other ones yeah okay got
him well the Confederate flag were you
referring to the Rachel KT Connell
picture The Bachelor girl I haven't seen
that one show me that one oh no I I I
don't know if if she was in front of a
Confederate flag I just heard that from
someone in here I can find it oh that's
not a photo you want to
take um images of the Tik tocker whose
real name is uh Campbell Pucket showed
her in front of a Confederate flag
wearing antibellum and milania Trump
costumes
yeah what's the problem mil what what it
said Melania Trump
costume says that's what it says I mean
use your imagination give me
break wasn't it supposed to be years ago
though isn't that what she said she said
it was 15 years ago she was a fan of
Melania Trump years ago this is People
magazine I don't know maybe cuz I mean
Trump was a big deal I guess he had
already had one failed bid for she's an
old head dude she's been Maga before
there was Maga respect
[Music]
man um so you guys want us to recreate
it
okay yeah the Bellum Confederate flag
photo yeah you should recreate with or
without that one uh the Pooky thing um
you don't there just was a post on the
sub writer about it but here's another
one from their catalog and
again I'm not saying this to be mean
they seem nice and all that but he looks
like
[__] like and I'm not a fashion I I'm
not one to talk but he looks corny as
hell in that outfit yeah great the
slicked back hair it's just there's The
Vibes are off M cuz he's trying to wear
this casual game day kind of outfit but
you you slicking back the hair like he's
in a suit yeah we're telling two
different stories that's a that's a
tough look to pull off you have to be
like Antonio Banderas to put your hair
back like that true and even him though
the thing is he doesn't slick it back
all the way it's a little Curly it's a
little mess curly in the back it's nice
yeah Pooky looks fire though yeah also
it looks like he may have bought this
shirt when he was a little bit lighter
when he was a little bit thinner and
trust me take it from a guy who knows
potentially am I guess they started
dating and got engaged 10 months later
married shortly after that's good
probably were like you did Anon Bell and
balls me
too I kid but let's take a look yeah she
looks good I like her thank you it's
giving a mob wife era
because that's a new trend in fashion
the mob wife oh mob it's not giving mob
wife
it's the four coat I think that's the
only what are we going to do about you
turn yesterday mob wife is is the look
that's in right now I actually do love
the mob mob wife look yeah I mean I've
always look but I'm fully embracing it
now do love the so I'm wearing my Kelly
I'm obsessed with her this vintage fur
is from my grandmother and I'm wearing
Adidas s's girlfriend I could be off
base here and not this you know height
matters at all but I'm getting the vibe
he's like 53 and she's like 48 something
do you do you know what I mean I do look
how big that look how big that [__]
door is compared to him like he's 53 Max
one small
man that's one small
man jeez
Buzz friend jeans and aritzia top love
those top let's called aritzia aritzia
top yes very cute what are you wearing
wearing my Rugby Jersey paig jeans it's
actually a mystery pair of boots that I
was giv us a gift years ago they're some
of my favorites but I don't even know if
they are they're really cute okay we're
going to go to the
chest they do love each other it seems
like yeah and that's all that matters
really at the end of the day isn't it
and not going to Anton Bell and
balls uh there's another thing I wanted
to do we can put it off cuz there's so
much I want to talk about but somebody
brought up which I hate that they
brought up yeah is that when we did the
period pain
simulator I theorized that because I had
so much fat it made it more painful
because it seemed to me that I was
experiencing more pain than everybody
else H yeah and so now people like oh
you you lost the weight so why don't you
go electrocute yourself
again so thank you to that suggestion
but we should try it we should try it we
should um it will take me just a minute
to set this up in the meantime so you
minutes why don't you do the ad read and
then by the time you're done we can
shock the hell out of you okay sounds
good ducky You're So
Cute Ducky he's calmed down a little bit
he's so much trouble such a little
Menace such a rascal just like a child
you know when we were getting for work
this morning
he just thrashed the room like there's
pee pads he tore up they were not peed
on they're new but he eviscerated them
he got a hold of like the toilet paper
cuz it's in like leaping distance and
shredded that oh my God he's amazing
he'll take stuff out of the trash it's
just yeah the trash we had to lift the
trash can off the ground cuz he he just
mob inside of it non stop on this boy
he's passed out now all right thank you
to our wonderful sponsor please please
consider uh supporting
Shopify in my opinion Shopify is one of
the best companies on the internet today
in terms of like e-commerce and
everything I mean not just in terms of
e-commerce in terms of any online
service it's such a fantastic company
such a fantastic product as you guys
might know we did Teddy fresh on Shopify
from day one and that was one of the
best decision we ever made in creating
our business absolutely from the first
day we knew nothing we didn't neither of
us knew how to code nether of us knew
how to do hosting or web any all that
all that stuff and somehow the two of us
were able to get on Shopify put together
some type of website and launch our
business just the two of us not knowing
anything and not only that it ran
smoothly it was never
offline you know and and again it
empowers people to
really go into e
Commerce with all the tools for Success
when you you frankly know nothing about
starting it it really is empowering in
that way yeah
um they also have tons of uh tools and
support tons of apps tons of apps and
the all the apps are super
professionally run by Third parties
there's so many that we use that are
invaluable that to adding to our our
business and they also have uh from the
beginning it's built so that you can
grow it as big as you
want our growth has been absolutely
seamless and um there's company there's
huge companies on chopy I'm not going to
I'm not going to speak one cuz I don't
want to be wrong but like billion
multi-billion dollar companies like the
big big ones they're on Shopify I
believe it it's good for everybody man
it's really
something so if you are you know selling
scented soaps or offering outdoor
outfits or anything in between or if
you're just drop shipping scams on
Facebook you
know I guess if if yeah if you're doing
any of that
stuff uh Shopify will help you sell it
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their in-person
POS system uh that's a point of sale for
all the people out there they give you a
little credit card swiper
and then you can sell stuff physically
and then it re it will send the money to
your store and reduce the inventory it's
crazy good analytics is all connected to
one place which is beautiful it really
is uh so that's the POS system yeah but
uh Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and uh sell more with
less effort thanks to Shopify magic your
AI high powered Allstar still I'm sure
that's
awesome I want it oh well I've been kind
of looking into it and I think what it
means is just that they have all kinds
of ser services that are applying AI
knowledge into it
so okay yeah they got the tech yeah ai's
I'm telling you man it's going to push
some product for you yeah but they got a
good deal here for you guys
um it's time for you to break through
it's time for that next level let's
let's start a business guys
um here's the deal sign up for $1 per
month trial at shop I know it $1 per
month trial period at shopify.com after
dark all lowercase so that's shopify.com
after dark lowercase on the after
dark now to grow your business no matter
what stage you're in one more time
shopify.com after dark for a one per
month
trial thank you and thank you to
everybody for considering uh supporting
our sponsor thank you all right let's
electrocute thank you oh yeah Dan Dan
brought those out suspiciously quickly
man I still have a lot of fat here you
know it's to hurt I saw some people
pointing out that you did it here
right here yeah
okay also I'm hairy does that matter I
feel like I still I'm just
I'm what otheres can we come up with
actually that one's kind of too low this
one's too low one should be like even
with your
belly yeah okay so there's one that will
oh this goes on the same side so like
here got it got it got it so I saw some
people pointing out that you did it with
me like uh 4 and 1/ half months ago yeah
yeah I don't know I forgot that I don't
know no I know I did and I still bailed
mhm but I I think I was a little bit
skin I remember thinking that I was
still fat you definitely lost a lot of
weight you just do it quarterly now part
of the show yeah yeah I mean listen I'm
not going to Lo this is it I've lost the
weight I'm I'm at
175 I don't think I'm getting any
thinner so I told Ethan I'm at 150 right
now we've never been so close I know
25 okay let this be the last time I
really hate this okay that just and
nobody call me a baby I'm just going to
tear him off me why am I doing this oh I
hate it all
right slowly Dan don't take out your
aggression on this this I'm starting to
tingle I know it it it comes all at once
okay I just I'm feeling tingling yeah
just slowly raising we're going to level
two initiating transfer to level two
right now it's just a tiny tingle
okay the first time you bailed at level
four M no slow down well hold on cuz I
don't feel it yet so there's something
it's going to come all at once ah okay
okay we're at three a [__] it just I
only feel it on this side okay there it
goes there it goes it just it it's not
pain it just feels
horrible I feel like my fat is frying
inside my skin ah [__] [__] this
[__] you're
bailing so I think the fat helped
before which was what listen I could
have done it I'm not here I'm not trying
to prove anything I'm not doing that
[__] listen you say oh do you want to
send the electric chair no I don't mhm
you want to put a sponge on my head
Dan but you would be pregnant if you
could right you would if you could
yeah what's up to me I'd be having all
the babies yeah and I would let you just
chill and you know MH I would let you
chill in fact here's what I would do for
you I would give birth and then I would
go home and clean and do everything for
you and I wouldn't complain about it so
but unfortunately I can't do that can't
do any of that
H that's a shame that wrist pains it's
hard for the do a
sponge you know the sponge just kills my
uh carpel tunnel
all
right so did I pass I don't know I think
you bailed sooner than you did last well
you put it up really far though at the
end that was at
four no I no you bailed made three like
three and a half yeah three and a half
but you made it to four last time so
didn't I make it up all the way the
first
time no I'm on the back no no no no you
guys put it on my back and then I went
up all the way why is it different I
don't know well I mean it's different
muscles let's put it on your back and
see if if how it is no ah okay I got up
to 10 I did too on my
back but if you're going to poo poo
let's put them on your back and see it's
fine it's fine it's
fine I've done it more than
anyone you know that's
true uh what else we got
here um
okay so before we let's do the Austin MC
broom stuff because exactly what I was
going to say so Austin MC broom okay
we're going to close the chapter on this
because we've been talking about him all
week and it's been a lot of fun it
really has been y but I feel like
there's been developments since our show
on Wednesday that has pretty much closed
the case on this it's jump It's jumped
the shark it is it did it jumped the
shark now I still have questions about
if they actually got the divorced cuz I
think they did they're getting divorced
yeah I think that's all real yeah and
okay all right let's see but there are
doubters I know well we'll find out
whole thing might be orchestrated so
here is this post that crushed on our
subreddit with zero up
votes damn yall I thanks guys yall
wanted to wait for the uh to watch it on
the show with us I appreciate
that all right here we go let's see what
he's up
to my girls to school I hate when
they're late it's just
oh [__]
[__] ah damn
it stupid ass
shoot oh my knee wait didn't he break
his
ankle huh didn't he break his ankle
playing
basketball um I don't know anything
about his basketball career I think
there's a funny he means recently we
watch the other day when he was at his
friend's house and he fell out the sh he
rolled his ank he didn't break his ankle
he said he rolled it yeah he rolled it
rolled it he seems fine though it's your
point right he's walking fine right I
mean yeah this is fake it's funny though
I I like that he's humiliating himself
willingly to school I hate when they're
late and just
oh [__] [__] oh man it is quite
interesting so that's what's happening
uh we move on a woman came to fix the AC
there was a plot line going on where his
um heater broke and that's why he had to
go live at his friend's house with the
newborn baby so here is the AC repair
person and this is really out of control
like did
did he should not have put all this
together this is
crazy
here here
guys sometimes I have to check out the
window just to make sure because people
have
been is the professional I do love the
idea of him in the camper and people
just coming and [__] harassing him
knocking saying what's up I mean the
camper is somewhere out there and he's
very public about
that could be in a community though I
feel like with how open he's been about
it it must be in negated Community
otherwise otherwise that's wild yeah
hello hey hello how you doing
hi I'm calling I got a call for you AC
is not working yeah yeah I'm calling
from a small AC
rers yeah yeah I get that are are you
sure you're in the right location a
technician I know what I'm doing I got a
call and I got a check this so obviously
fake wait till you see
her the implication of his behavior is
really crazy
actually okay
um yes there's a to I'm here to report
what's going on where is the short
problem here the Yelp reviews real yeah
yeah why is he doubting what's the twist
okay let me she W there she must be like
like in her underwear or something or
like with a crack bite out of her
mouth all
right um
so the this is right here it's uh this
is the the small AC unit here okay okay
so we got here a little short problem
where is The Big Unit right here so how
long she's a little
person oh what a
Twist so he's like yo this little
person's here to fix my AC are you in
the right place and they said from it's
small AC small AC small AC yeah then he
goes little problem little God oh
God why' you have to do the little
people
um Goofs you could have done something
else why a little person repair an air
conditioner literally there's dude
they're probably really good at it and
what's the problem what do you mean are
the Yelp reviews real probably I know
because because she's
little come on
man pretty pretty out of pocket come on
man so yeah definitely getting this is a
this is a shark jump moment for sure
sure this was it for me just like over I
understand this this is really my life
here's the thing like I and the idea of
having like a zany AC repair person and
filming it is is a good idea for his
story arc but the way he did it wasn't
funny no and also it was just kind of
mean for no reason you know just OD like
oh oh there's a little person oh my God
you guys seeing this she's so small
yeah okay
stupid she's stupid Austin she sounded
funny though so Props to her um she was
playing the bit well I suppose yeah on a
good show yeah I was buying the
character so Dan says that's when he
jumped the shark I think he jumped the
shark when he put out his new
single
um seen that later but yeah uh this has
9 million views damn okay so it's wor so
he's doing well with all this oh he's
still posting the ace family bro you're
not allowed to post there anymore
there's no more Ace family the the
family's broken where's the Austin
McBroom Channel I just want to mention
before we move on that that lady then
tries to seduce him well where's that
it's number uh let see in the oh we
don't need to sa that yeah I do it's
going to be so stupid bro that of course
that's why we're watching it we're not
watching it it it's going to be every
single comment and Reddit post we're not
watching it cuz it's good then all right
all right all right all
right she tried to seduce him that's
mania this guy's a
maniac
so I think it's I think it's been 20
minutes yeah I'm getting in there okay
you know still hard to work here yeah so
wait what are you doing what are you
doing I I need to concentrate you know
oh
my
I need to go
to you know it's getting I just what's
the
problem well we haven't seen the reveal
yet what is she doing that's got him so
upset big
Z oh God [__] fire [__] fire bro
what does he want his his friend to
throw her out or something his assistant
I guess
yeah you know you cute you hot um I
just he's going for the Academy Award
and he didn't he doesn't need to do all
this he's trying to make Catherine
jealous it's Oscar bait yeah oh you
think he's so that's a good theory it
was probably like a thought he was like
she could also seduce me
true I do have a tool for you here to I
don't need any tools um I just got out
of a divorce I just got hot of yeah yeah
yeah I just got the divorce um oh so we
can celebrate
then no uh I'm still trying
to say what is I think I've seen this
movie before plotline seems a little
familiar you
have no but he definitely was inspired
by
something the repair person plotline
yeah so classic I'm tried well maybe
maybe
AB it's real life mimicking art and not
the other way around
[Music]
uhhuh you know it be funny if love all
of a sudden was like I actually do think
this is
real this is real this part's real
actually
yeah what if he just could prove somehow
at the end of all this that everything
everything was true I would be blown
away and I would have I would admit that
we were wrong here's the AC repair
company I'll sub yeah yeah if he can
prove it's all real I'm subbing
right I'll even put notification on Slam
that Bell he was
bullshitting what what' you say
what you know I'm still trying to
recover like I'm just I'm still healing
going through my healing process and I
appreciate all of the um I'm not sure if
you gave me compliments or not just now
I couldn't understand it but um I got to
check something in the back in the
system you got to what I got to check
something more in the back in the system
what the [__] so she changed the [__]
dude this is
wild yes all the way in the back right
there oh my God okay
Queen it's getting hot in
here
what excuse me the um
this this is where the AC is it's still
not working yeah I was checking the
other unit right here okay but what's
happing my God what is happening he he
hired someone to come fix his AC no okay
there for that so now she's on the in
the RV and she changed into lingerie and
she's coming on there
baby it's 100% real so even if this is
fake it obviously is the fact that he's
recording this [__] in an RV outside his
ex-wife's house with his kids right
there is so [__] weird I canot get
over it it's very weird well also like
this me the um I I don't know if anyone
thinks this is still real so but he's
just holding his phone in her face the
whole time right what do you mean this
is
real board yeah I thought this was all
real still real to me damn
it F we got to get still real to be Dam
a man the two of them need to be
working she's crushing it fix you it's
very funny wa um okay
so
um um you
had the neighbors probably think they're
making a meth or something in that van
there something something's going on in
there there's all kinds of people always
running around all kinds of gear yeah
strange characters coming and going
yeah
um [__] where's my house when I need it
h
[__] excuse me
um it's time it's time uh you have to be
somewhere what what is that what is that
can can I see that
please be careful with that that I don't
want that to hurt you it's a little too
big what does she mean oh come on the
little what ear is it man oh my God I
didn't understand he keeps doing like oh
it's a little too big for you what year
is it he goes it's a little problem it's
like bro
seriously yesh it's like Ace Ventura
it's before Ace Ventura Ace Ventura
didn't have any little little uh phobia
little
phobia he transphobia a lot of
transphobia oh yeah horn is a
man they all start Marino yeah I didn't
I haven't thought about that movie in
decades [__] the second one's better
anyways yeah so why she give him a screw
driver I didn't understand that is
definitely wait a minute that is
definitely too big can I see that please
yes okay you can see that all right I'm
going to just step outside
really so oh this is this is yeah the
shark has been jumped at this point
oh I'm curious is it weird to post this
kind of content when your claim to fame
is a family Vlog Channel and your fans
are all kids is that a crazy think so
his fans aren kids I don't think his
fans aren't kids I I hate to tell you I
think they're grown ass people that's
true we met a bunch of them I we saw
what their fans are they Snapchat is a
bunch of kids Snapchat is claimed to f
is literally having a family show is it
weird yes he has an he has a deal with
Snapchat obviously that's probably all
meant to be kid-friendly too yeah I mean
it's not like bad bad bad but it's
pretty I mean if you're like a
5-year-old I don't know how young six I
mean you know you don't know what the
hell's going on there yeah's Snapchat
it's also weird like you do this outside
of the house where the kids are that is
weird what's Dad doing in the RV yeah
Dad's playing yeah he's he's role
playing a littleit but I think it's safe
to say the family days are
gone now we're in a whole new Wild West
kind of world where Catherine is
probably going to
start having um little people come fix
her
AC exactly we have the whole they'll
have the
whole well that's what I'm saying the
other day when she posted all those
vibrators on her story like it's not
that it's weird for anyone else but just
because they have a family channel and
they're going through the divorce that's
not appropriate yeah
oh come on E all right so that but
that's not even the the worst part here
he at the end of all
this put out a oh God I didn't know
about this he put I didn't know it was
about this he misses Catherine somebody
said I was a teacher and can confirm his
fanss are
children really I think there's a lot of
kids that watch family channels mhm it's
a mix I think you I feel like it's
people with families I hate it's weird
it's weird to say because I can't
imagine wanting to watch that as an
adult yeah other young parents no I
think definitely kids they post like
surprise like they surprise their kids
with gifts or whatever kids love Hitler
you look through their videos kids love
Hitler no shot you don't agree at no
what I think there's probably some kids
but yeah I mean some kids but I mean
like kids don't predominantly young
adults when you say kids what age are we
talking
about um below 50
dude those kids don't want to watch that
this [__] I would never low 16 like 15
and stuff like that that that they're
watching like uh scy they're doing
watching like Minecraft
bro like hit blocks one of their most
popular videos is like getting stuck in
a bowl of
cereal it's like kids content no yeah
that yes it's a little dice one-year-old
goes grocery shopping for her parents
that's cute that could be that could
appeal to the Young Adult Family oh sure
but I think kids also kids yeah yeah how
young okay whatever who cares I I was
watching a recap on some of their uh
scams yesterday and the first one well
one of the first ones about the hats
like you had to buy a hat and you could
participate in a drawing for a car
Austin says you know and and if you need
it you know if you're younger save up
your lunch money he makes a line a
comment like that to buy a hat and I
don't think they gave the car away ever
which is epic reminder thank you AB we
did a Austin or Ace family content Court
a while ago so that's still up if youall
want to revisit a classic right there
speaking of content Court we're working
on something it's so good it's coming
I'm so excited I think there it's going
to bring a lot of I think there's going
to be a lot of backlash after for real
from the from bad people but I'm excited
good people to have a backlash from
exactly but this has been whatever it is
I'm not going to tell you who it's about
but there's been a lot of effort a lot
of time gone into this so this is our
big comeback
yeah and somebody's going to
jail for
life so anyway Austin Dro
uh okay is that the one for the the
sexual unit one or is that just Law and
Order that's just general Law and Order
they all they all have the dong dong
okay yeah asking because of Jeff's
podcast they played it and you asked
them that you're like yeah yeah yeah I I
was off Bas there apologies to Jeff's
crew just want to say I had that first
though just want to say that I know Zach
I know okay we all know we all
know um uh so here is he dropped a song
and this is the newest development okay
about him missing Catherine so here it
is oh
man this is tough for
me I don't understand man this is tough
for me are wild I want to make a song I
just don't know how to put into okay
he's still wearing the stained life okay
that's kind of a
vibe D I need your help man I wrote
something and I need you to Freestyle
for
me I miss
you I love you I've been in this
RV no
heat together for 8 years we don't even
speak you know that I miss you I'll be
watching you right through the
tree been missing kids lately I've been
living
alone I got but sometimes I just want to
be
home we got C night I Beering to my
bones would you steal my a girl would
youal
[Music]
my hold on Dan I'm I'm actually feeling
this this is awesome it's hilarious like
all the [__] AC jokes and peeking out
the window
fun it's honestly pretty good yeah it's
pretty good I mean you know what I like
that he was like I wrote it but here's
somebody else going to sing it yeah cuz
I can't sing he knows his talents he
knows his strengths know his limits he's
a famous rapper apparently he's the guy
who's staying with DG m i mean I get
that yeah that's what's happening yeah
well I don't know if you know I don't I
didn't know who he was no I don't I love
that he's wearing pants with his own
face on
it oh yeah
what I want to get is Austin put out a
couple singles so why isn't he singing
oh he did yeah he's got like some songs
doesn't he he's got a pro here to do it
for
him this is going to be a certified
iTunes number
one or should we just let him stay up at
the window trying to check on my baby I
can act like I'm okay but I'm faking I
don't know if I can handle you dating
it's been a month I don't know if I make
it I got lost when I was going to class
making of me I'm going out you and all
the kids is all that I had I was a
husband now I'm only a
dad the home pillow okay wait wait wait
wait wait okay I don't think he's
getting a divorce anymore I think it's
all fake oh really interesting I think
it's all fake now welcome I'm out you're
welcome to the crew this video solidifi
that it's all fake for
me which is pretty impressive I have to
say Obviously hedge any compliments I
give him with the fact that he's like a
prolific
scammer [__] but who on YouTube
isn't frankly you know
[Music]
Bridge you feeling a
bridge that you and all the kid is all
that I had I was a husband now I'm only
your dad damn I've been missing the kids
lately I've been living
alone the RV that I got nice but
sometimes I just want to be home and La
we got cold night I be shivering down to
my bones would you steal my Ace girl
would you steal my
Ace okay guys that was pretty good that
was pretty good honestly and it was shot
pretty funny too yeah that was [__] I
hate to say this whole Arc has been
pretty funny like as a whole kind of
thing and a roller coaster ride and not
knowing but then at the end it becomes
very obvious I
mean Jesus Christ got to live the best
life possible like I'm S I got to give
it up to Austin this has been
insane right I like the song that song
the video was funny as [__]
dude he's like the Danny ocean of
YouTube like you think he can't pull it
off again but somehow he pulls off a
bigger scam true like I never thought he
could pull something like this off which
was part of the reason why I never
believed it was
real or that I believe that it was real
I think you're giving him too much
credit really yeah so good he fell into
his hands people been accusing him of
having a divorce y y you think it fell
into his he's just like yeah I might as
well fake it [__] song the song is good
the song was funny but he did nothing he
just sat there like has a talented
musician with him though I don't know
nothing about I don't think I think
you're not trying to give my boy credit
giv enough Ace hat I think Ace hat
business family is back all right all
right d 10 million views I mean I don't
know have to
speakok I got listen I I got to keep it
real yeah I mean my boys got me giggling
and and I'm a hater me too I'm a hater
hater I would usually have notes on the
video but I feel like I don't it was it
was good Harley says I think it's all
real and this is his way of getting her
back if it was okay if this was if they
were actually getting divorced he
wouldn't do this I don't think he's
really trying to get her back like that
I don't think they're breaking up I
think they're still together and then it
all ties in with what we discovered in
the beginning which is he was in her bed
did you see that photo no so okay can we
show Ela that cuz that this is a
evidence that we've been kind of putting
out of mind for a while but when we
first started talking about
this we discovered that in one of the
posts he did about he's like oh I can't
sleep whatever mhm and then if you
compare it to Catherine's bedroom and
her bed uh headboard he's in her bed
there's no question about it I sent it
yeah thank you when he's supposedly out
already yeah yeah they're broken up he's
in the RV oh so why is he in her bed
check this out okay so here is the bed
and the headboard yep very unique
looking mhm now here is his oh I can't
sleep
yeah that's that's obviously that a th%
her room like it's not even possible
anywhere else yeah for the record that
that photo of Austin should be the cover
of Dream song his song
nightmare right here I can't sleep that
would be a good collab a nightmare a
night nightmare to to push it even
further do you think he knowingly took
that photo see and to like make it clear
look I'm still in her bed for sure yeah
they both I think they're both in on it
and like yeah let's stir the pot and
then the next day Katherine was like now
I need to buy him stuff from Sephora so
he stops coming in the house hold on
someone said read Katherine's response
is there something that we're missing
for her by the way shout out to YouTube
who is fluctuating our views by like 50
15,000 every minute so
annoying I mean as long it I can't tell
is it actually booting people out I
don't know I don't think so the the I'm
looking at the graph in the back end and
it it's not doing that on like the main
graph so what does it say back
there uh just shy of 40K it's at 39.2 so
I just saw it okay whatever so um what
did Catherine you know whenever you guys
say there's issues I'm when I'm
listening I have no issues okay it just
it might just be a a glitch a graphic
glitch
yeah
um all right well so what is her
response that people are talking about I
sent
it oh hold on me and Olivia both sent
the same thing and it sent in a weird
format yeah I can't you sent me some
unopenable
file what the hell what the hell did I
just open
all right here is Katherine's
response wow it a race she posted this I
guess they're both on Snapchat both
posted the same thing she
said okay this is a fan message I
absolutely adore you right yeah
absolutely adore you so I hate to ask
the Dreadful question but Austin making
songs about the situation making
clickbait out of it how does it affect
you ho that's rude oh it's probably not
finished she said I'm grateful to be
evolved because his behavior and coping
mechanisms is are Beyond me he tells me
he's doing well though so I trust him
but as for the song I laughed and Loki
has a little ring to it oh
[__] her response seems
[Laughter]
realit but I mean that could be part of
the of the whole thing I'm confus I'm
back so confused I think okay we'll have
we'll see we'll see we'll
see this could be like a you know sitcom
101 here Austin's being the goofy funny
guy and Katherine's playing the uh yeah
the straight you know y yeah it's
possible but I like the idea they do
that they I I foresee this backfiring
horrifically for them in what way oh
absolutely if if the if they're not
really divorcing people will be so
well you guys aren't thinking in the way
that they think like scammers they're
going to say we found each other again
we're in love again yeah they won't say
they what you're saying they'll they'll
somehow find each other gotcha and we'll
all know we'll all know but yeah I think
they'll just say we [__] troll the
internet over like that I that's the one
part where me and love disagree heavily
I don't think they'd ever do that I
personally at this point it's so
obviously become a joke that I don't
think they have a lot to lose by saying
that yeah they their fans are die hard
yeah I think be really upset
damn I mean they took us all on a
journey nobody can complain about that
this is fre we're fans we're not like
hard hardcore invested in this they got
to be loving this yes I'm just saying
that the people are really into this
hardcore will be really upset if they
found out that it's fake yeah well if
they don't know by now I don't know how
what I don't know how to help them me
and L are nobody's and I I did click
bake once and people wanted to [__]
kill us so I well the I'm pregnant thing
well
H
yeah you don't joke about that AB yeah I
learned I'm kidding guys are
fine um so in the meantime Austin has
actually quite inspired
me um
because I don't know if it's real or not
but the one thing that I can give him
credit for is like he's gotten a ton of
juice and so I'm wondering I'm wondering
you know I'm trying to get with Snapchat
I'm trying to get some you know new
fans and I'm wondering if maybe Austin
has some ideas for
meh and with that being
said let's take a look if you don't want
a huge opportunity to work with the best
only fans a agency it's not too late if
you change your mind are you doing this
only F thing I keep hearing about it
that you're messaging girls only fans
girls I don't know what you're talking
about where did you hear that everywhere
it's not what you think I'm not trying
to like sleep with them I'm just trying
to pimp them not trying to cheat I'm
just trying to cheat them like out of
money it's the only fans thing baby no
it's going to be big money it trust me
baby this is this is a huge opportunity
for why you keep doing this can you not
it's very aggressive I'm done I want
your stuff out of the house by
tonight I'm sure she's not
serious welcome everybody to my house
tour I want to show you guys around my
my uh temporary
place this here is the master closet I
got more hanging space up here as you
can see this is my entertainment center
the moment doesn't turn on
yet I am working on running
electricity from the
office hey you can't run electricity
from the building into your [__] car
this who I I can I am dude take all of
this stop bro St the [__] out of the
building St the [__] out of the building
who are you to tell me that [__] you I
didn't do anything
skyroof nice natural lighting did you
know I could do
this did you know I could do this the
master uh
bathroom you don't want to drink this
okay AB holy [__] you scared me what's
up D I got to go I got to drop this off
the El all right I'll see you later for
the show okay buddy good work see you
thank
get lonely out here you know what I'm
saying space for one
more the master bedroom the master suite
here it is spacious I have three limbs
touching the ceiling later today when
you have free time can you get me the uh
I want the switch from the house if you
can bring it here okay this one's a
little unusual but trust me I have a
good reason for asking a couple of pairs
of her
panties really preferably from the dirty
h
I don't want to grab any of her
panties is that necessary I was just
kidding okay a
joke
H but uh seriously I don't know if you
see something on the floor maybe it's
easy to you don't have to do something
anything invasive Ethan also the master
um kitchen as you can see all kinds of
things are happening
there
what's up dog no I'm kidding you want a
hot dog um is that Grill even on is this
is this lead is there lead here there
lead leaking over on this what's this
about that's true yeah I'm cool on the
dog this one's fine though I'm cool on
the dog dog thanks all right dog see you
later dog bro you want a dog thanks man
appreciate it enjoy brother nice to see
you
okay also another on Suite
um toilet
restroom little boy room um don't drink
that by the way hey Alfredo and ducky
you guys want to come up to grab them
actually they're happy to see me they
haven't seen me in a while you you just
you can't be near the kids I'm so sorry
to do this the kids come on baby we'll
figure it out okay buddy they can't be
near you I didn't do anything making the
best of uh this situation here trying to
stay close to the family keep an eye on
everybody stay close to the dogs make
sure everything's okay
what is he doing ladies out there you at
don't you make me act up don't be
thirsting for me in the
shower here will you hold that for me
just gu just keep it still okay
I'm getting all wet I don't I don't I
don't know dude I I don't know this is
weird what's weird hey guys what's up
just checking in thanks everyone for
caring so much about me and watching
these updates it was a cold night last
night
actually Ethan hey what's up I know this
was like a joke to you know to get you
famous on Snapchat and all that but I I
it's getting too pathetic I don't think
I can do it anymore but the views are
crazy I don't know if you've seen it I
know but it's really affecting me just
being myself I'm getting really not
attracted to you with this look and
really the yeah you got to come back
inside I I can't do this okay all right
all right I'll wrap it up
[Music]
okay yeah there it is
is unfortunately um as you can see it
was going well but I think some may say
too well too well and uh I had to call
it off but it was really good it was fun
while it lasted MH um but shout out to
Austin for the inspiration and thank you
good work everybody that's another
that's another one in the whole we
actually we worked our buns off pretty
good on this one we we shot a lot on uh
Tuesday
we haven't done that in a while yeah it
was fun it was yeah we shot all that one
afternoon just want to give a shout out
to Ian he was the uh he he edited that
so he did a oh yeah Cam's not here he's
sick so Ian threw that together that was
impressive you edited that all today Ian
uh I was here doing it came yesterday as
well nice job edited and produced by you
thank you
cool very
good very
good ah
I just want to watch it again
frankly um but that being said uh Let's
do let's do it this it's time for the
main course here the failure
podcast what's up
game what's going on Ethan happy Friday
happy Friday my friend what are you guys
cooking we're doing the sauce Nikki
Special Sauce my BR from my brother from
another mother what's in the Nikki
Special
Sauce let's find out let's find out
right I'm ready you ready to learn yep
all right look look over here you start
with your garlic right m is it brown
it's brown okay leave it on a low flame
all right okay your Tomatoes your
crushed tomatoes some crushed tomatoes
baby can at a time is that what what he
really sounds like or is he doing a
Godfather you should ask him oh that's
how Nick sen that's amazing this is
straight up the cooking scene from the
jail scene in Godfather in a good fell
yeah good fell not too many onions in
the sauce bab put the tomatoes in the
sauce denapoli yep supposed to be a good
tomato put a little water wait you know
put a little water in
it
in hdden it with the wine it mix it in
here wow wow
[Applause]
iny nice that looks good okay it has to
be with style like do it in style what
kind of pasta are you guys going to be
throwing in there or is it sauce for
something else make the sauce first Gabe
we're gonna make pasta comes later what
what do you what's your
plan what's the pasta plan you decide on
pasta later spaghett about it spaghett
about it of course it's spaghetti spaget
and you guys got meat bells on there or
just noodles he pay attention now right
pay attention you got the sauce going
right pay attention now
get oh God Pi your sausage up pick your
sausage up oh the sausage no
right in the put over here don't drip
put the sausage over here Sal over here
salm don't it in nice okay boom drop it
in nice light drop it in nice
Gabe get it in there Gabby show some
respect for those
sausages to me nice honestly I'm with
Gabe I I like to just mix with
everything but everything there's get it
come on you have to respect the
tradition of whatever's going on there
all right what's next me the POR the
pork that's [__] por get the pork
whoa what do we got there what do what
kind of pork is that just like pork chop
yeah like pork chop pork chops it giv it
gives the soft flavor right Dave yep I'm
Jewish so I don't know anything about
pork if I was wrong I'm really I'm
just so we just throw in pork
kosher kosher no I'm not Kosher I just
don't really [__] with pork for some
reason um careful so wait do you do you
could put that in there for just the
flavor and then you take it out or how
do you how do you eat that let it you
let it cook in there yeah let it cook
some people don't they don't do it that
way I I cook my
pork right in the sauce right that's
amazing actually we had it in a jar many
years ago but we just didn't have the
money
behind but Stir It
gab all right
damn all right you guys are eating good
tonight get it smooth get it to work
smooth okay smooth it up Gabe come
on okay put a little wrist into the
thing
hey
woo
woo cooking pasta baby [__] put some
basil in there let's get some basil in
there
kab put some basil lots of Basil that's
a huge a lot of
Basil keep
going easy
okay that's a lot that's a
lot hey come on that's a lot of garlic
[Music]
powder get thean on there
you can go big on the oregano I feel
like no
okay what we got some do we do we put
bay leaves in here or no you could we
could put fresh basil too yeah put
moreen that [__] sauce look at that
[__] sauce look at that [__] sauce
all right we can't see e for that much
we what are we miss little cheese little
gred
cheese the
parmesan
else we don't want Ean have a right we
sugar absolutely what is that Sugar oh
sugar oh I love
that get it smooth get it smooth easy
nice get that Smo get that b get nice
game hey come
on wasting the
salce nice nice look at that look at
that look at that look at that Gabe
you're doing a good job nice and EAS get
that sausage down you don't want to look
sticking up that's the style of making
the sauce
wow and so now we cover it how long we
cooking that
for every 15 minutes or so we Stir It Up
yep about an hour two hours but it's mhm
then what you boil your water boil your
water put your pasta in you make your
spaghetti and my
balls Gabe so are you is Gabe in charge
of the pasta is he gonna Gabe is in
charge you got to keep an eye on the
short 15 minutes all right Gabe we'll
check in on you in 15 minutes make sure
you stir it stir the sauce baby stir the
sauce baby it's Friday stir the sauce
baby s the [__] stir the [__]
sauce stir the [__] sauce stir the we
can't s that freaking
flops the think show the
think that looks good good all right
listen thank you guys that was really
exciting
yeah awesome
and uh can we see it when it's
cooked or you could stop by BR sauce I
got some for Zach too you bring z sauce
thank you Gabe I appreciate that I'm
stoping samp oh [__] you
better [__] you get a plate of that I
would come but it's my son's birthday
okay sing Happy Birthday happy birth
what's your son's name Bruce Bruce happy
birth
birthday happy birthday to Bruce happy
birthday dear
Bruce birthday to
[Applause]
[Music]
you all right Gabe great to see you man
looks like you guys GNA you have a good
weekend lined up already with that pasta
all right can't wait for you to taste
can't wait for you to taste and I want
to
say
what what was
that what did it I saw his mouth move
Zoom filtered him
out wait oh he he is saying something
yeah bro
said wait why did Zoom filter poor Gabe
out I think it because he just got so
loud so quickly try again Gabe one more
time
it it removes the audio Gabe maybe
whisper it oh my
God okay what why is he said I love you
I love you Gabe I love you buddy I do
and if you guys want to support Gabe
he's on a
cameo G for any for any occasion frankly
I think it's a it would be a great gift
let's see the full day right around the
corner true let's see the fit I see red
shoes that shirt looks
fire are those Jay's I don't know what
that means H hokas is so
comfortable comfortable guys thanks for
checking in love to see you have a great
weekend Gabe it's Friday all right buddy
it's Friday Friday Friday
baby
for
all right Gabe listen I can sit here all
day I
could thanks Gabby take care talk to you
that's Gabe well that's Uncle Gabe
that's Uncle Gabe there he is making
that sauce that's Uncle Gabe huh I'll
tell you I never seen fun little uh yeah
I've never seen a dish like this I never
seen pork cooked like that and sausage
but it's got to be good I know I know
the Italians they do the sauce I've seen
them do the the sausage and the sauce
that's like the bologan I guess right or
is that ground beef ground beef no but
the Italian sausage they [__] they put
that in everything don't they the
Italian but I wonder if they like
they're going to chop it up cuz I've
seen it in like
chunks I have no idea I would assume yes
but I don't know putting it raw like
that was very surprising yeah put it raw
I want to see the final dish me too it's
going to be great man some of chat was
confused cuz they recognized uh that's
his brother-in-law he's an actor Chad
was Wonder doing there his um that's his
brother-in-law that's the relation yeah
he's a famous actor he is yeah that's
Nick Nick's dad Nick Nick's dad okay
that's Nick senior isn't that funny was
a funny weird connection he seems like a
great guy though yeah yeah he's the man
he let me and have some of his uh cigars
from his private collection oo now
that's respect yeah as respect so is he
Italian is that what's going on he's
actually Italian I believe he from
Brooklyn so um I think he is Italian
yeah like all Brooklyn right everyone
from Brooklyn
Italian all right okay I got a pee and
then we're gonna we are going to jump
head
first
into what can only be
described as the greatest cinematic
production by one of the greatest of
alltime producers m
of all time of all time of all time the
failure podcast right I'll be right
back think I should take actually this
might be a good opportunity uh El I
wanted to to give you guys the gift that
uh we got for Bruce me cuz it's super
cute well I something to do while you're
gone okay let me
see oh
first of all that's so sweet you
guys oh my God that is too
funny wow oh that is so so sweet that
he's going to look
awesome oh my God the good yeah the
shoes are my favorite part oh oh my
God you guys this is crazy oh my God
baby shoes
dude the box is [__] adorable I don't
know if people are used to this I wasn't
used to it cuz I've never seen it
before oh look at that that's so smart
yeah we noticed that and we're like
something like this that is so smart cuz
I was saying let's just get him some
Crocs cuz I know it's a nightmare to put
shoes on kids but when I saw that I'm
like that's genius these are so
cute we know it's not his usual style
but kind of want to make himy we want to
corrupt them as early as we can I love
it thanks thank you of course oh I can't
wait for Ethan to see
this I love little tiny
shoes it's like the cutest thing in the
world we also got Teddy some um bath
bomb so he doesn't feel left out I
see thank you no problem
a yeah Teddy loves the bath bombs he's
so
funny
yep Dr pimple pop presentent us some the
other day oh yeah he loves going to lash
that's like an
activity yeah they had like this cute um
bath art set so that's what we got for
him oh yeah every time we're at the mall
Lena wants to stop at Lush to get theore
one I was like didn't you just get him
one she's like oh he wanted the the
Mario or something or some special one
that he was excited about surprise one
yeah and whenever there's like a season
like Halloween or something he likes
like the limited edition ones
these are so cute let me see is it yeah
that's his size
nice I'll send you guys a picture yeah
I'm excited to see how it look we were
trying to get a different there wasn't a
lot of uh outfits in his his size I
thought there was too much they too
matchy matchy but I'm sure it look cute
no it's cute
[Music]
yeah um did you need go to the bathroom
by the way sorry we didn't mean to keep
you um it's not too urgent yet I was
just thinking I'll go cuz Ethan went
but okay I want to see the baby bump oh
my God it's getting
crazy I can barely move
[Music]
now she's ready to
go oh look what they got Bry that's so
cute
he got his first pair of Jays
yeah that's what you call him right
yeah sneaker head is born by the way
check this
out that's the real yeah that's the
magic right there no way dude okay that
is awesome yeah I've never you this that
yeah they were talking
about laced up he's going to love those
by the way did you guys try these
cupcakes from Toddy these are nuts
they're so bomb the [__] very good oh
quickly before we move on I just wanted
to uh shout out a fan made something
really [__] cool um and I actually I
I bought it from him and then he sent
along with it a bunch of other really
cool stuff you all remember well how
could you forget the uh the Mega Man
meme I have grown up with Mega Man there
it
is that's cool this guy made a mega Dan
that's so cool action figure his name is
uh Cosmic Evil toys and then yeah he
along with it he sent he also made a zil
zonka this is so [__] cool it's so
[__] cool dude so thank you man again
thank you very much super cool and uh
yeah he's on Instagram as Cosmic Evil
toys uh does some really cool art and
stuff too so I'm assuming Che him out it
wouldn't be easy to mass-produce those
uh probably not I mean I don't know the
first thing about making action figures
but yeah these are all like custom made
and painted and stuff so that's awesome
but yeah I was so stoked on it
um this is so sick I'm cold so I just
went to grab a sweater but this isn't
out yet right no not yet but it will
be I was so hot I don't know why so
freezing it's pretty cold but you're
pregnant you never know what's going to
happen I had to take off my jacket I was
like dying all
right
we've all waited oh do we want who's
ready to fail do we want to show the
picture of um oh yeah little baby
MH we got photos of uh
Sunny Just So Good by the way H thank
you
to lots of support today thank you guys
so
much um
specifically I want to thank I'll thank
everybody but I want to thank Bella
Simmons 50 gifted
Chrissy Sherlock 20 gifted wow thank you
guys so nice and all the Don we'll we'll
go back and read
them I'm sending it on WhatsApp I'm
looking for the oh got it here I can
open it easily
here uh one second El got wait don't cut
to it don't cut to
it okay I just want to zoom in in case
there's anything
personal okay yeah you're
good there's there he is
little Sunny little Sunny is that crazy
he's already beaming my radiant little
boy
cute I felt like he already looks like
Ethan yeah
Sunbeam how can they look how do the
boys look like me they're both so like
beautiful and cute
oh what I think is funny is that they're
both so different looking from each
other but they both look like you
I I I don't know I don't see I don't see
it like that but everybody says it but
yeah they bruy and Teddy are look look
different they're not like look at that
I feel like I've never seen an
ultrasound that looked so clear yeah
right so is that his hand this like the
skeletal hand I think it might be it was
moving a lot and he was like putting his
hand in his mouth and then scking it out
wow that's C
crazy yeah it's
awesome cute he's probably so chill in
there right now yeah and then he gets
torn out into a cold he's naked he's
cold it's bright the trauma of birth
with us a lifetime the first and the
greatest trauma that's
right and I go welcome I start screaming
it's
sunny welcome to Papa's
house um all right who's ready to fail
I'm so
ready so I'm going in somewhat raw and
regular on this actually totally we're
trying to find the Rost of the RW we
have our favorite
timestamps
um is there anything okay so some
background on his first
guest you know about this this is so yes
yes yes here's his channel failure the
podcast
Ryan you are such an
idiot like just imagine being Ryan
Kavanaugh hey suck de
balls what the [__] the that's the
graphic the throwing the tomatoes look
how shitty that graphic
is Cam sent he found it he found it in
like 10 seconds cam found the uh the
stock tomato that he used oh my God here
wait hold hold up hold hold up for real
bro you're the you're big time producer
failure that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever seen oh and look it's in the back
like the Hollywood
Sign welcome to your failure yeah he
carries that around with him cuz in the
promo photo he had it behind him there
too he brings he Ryan walks around with
a big sign that says
failure the intro is so underwhelming
welcome to failure welcome to so a first
a note on his first uh guest Nigel
lco uh litho litho Nigel litho he's 74
he was the executive producer of Pop
Idol and American Idol and has also
acted as an on-screen judge on several
Talent programs as himself MH two former
contestants of All-American Girl are
suing him over alleged essay According
To Us Media the lawsuit claims that lith
go uh openly groped them during filming
of the Series in 2003 and made unwanted
advances after the show ended and if
that's not enough Paula
Abdul is also suing him claiming
multiple instances of
assault so he's he's a equal opportunity
uh assaulter and that and that just
happened like uh one month ago yeah like
this is fresh and Ryan's like you know
what you know what I think I think
there's not many people willing to come
on this show and because he's been
disgraced yeah he's like oh [__]
somebody wants to talk to me do you
think that he's going to bring this
up that's funny um he sort of does he
does sort of he cuz Nel talks about not
being on his show anymore and then
Ryan's like oh yeah what what happened
with that but we'll we we'll get into it
well M it's so funny if he really didn't
know you start telling him we pointed
out last time Ryan has a real affinity
for ex Showbiz people who are also um
sexual assaulters allegedly about Nigel
Harvey of course who he kissed lovingly
on the head yeah is convicted Bri kavana
is a force of nature he's in jail
actually there was also a Variety
article that was released alongside the
podcast and he talks about Nigel and
that as well if you go down to six in
the dock I put some different uh things
he said new variety articles just
released this is Ryan about Nigel so
here he had to say about his uh
wonderful guest who's being sued by
multiple women for
essay Nigel litho who obviously is going
through his own stuff right now that's a
quote from Ryan that's a that's a really
interesting way to put it because he
he's like he's going through stuff I'm
going through stuff it's a different
level of stuff yeah I mean what me and
you are going through Ryan is stuff but
it's not it's not stuff it's not that
kind of stuff like you know give
yourself some credit
man I mean you're just a douche and a
[__] and an idiot loser you're not a
sexual criminal right take take some
pride in that
yeah um and I'll say this to Ryan's
credit you know the dude was a big- time
producer in Hollywood for a decade and
as far as I know there's not one
accusation of of sexual impropriety
against him against Ryan yeah that's
true so I I I give Ryan credit for that
yeah I mean it's a low bar in Hollywood
managed to clear he he as far as I know
has not sexually assaulted any give it
up we have to be fair and balanced
here but I
mean I got to I just be real I call it
like I see it he's a m he's a raped
anybody no that we know
of no accusations no all right so he
said thank
you you're welcome we give credit words
you're
welcome uh he's going through his own
stuff right now but he's co-creator of
American Idol creator of So You Think
You Can Dance and his story is pretty
incredible obviously he's right now
going through another challenge in his
life but I think he'll come out of it
strong Brian what are you doing dude why
are you saying that Paula ABD duel is
suing him for multiple instances of
assault do we want him to come out
strong after
something what Ryan does on the opposite
end of the spectrum is Bryce Hall what
why you
gonna why do this to your boy Bryce Hall
don't bring him up like that do not
invoke his name in speaking of sexual uh
crimes Bryce Hall God who is arguably
the most famous influencer right now
nobody would argue that and listen I
like
Bryce he's a nice guy I enjoyed having
him on the show nobody argues that I
don't think Bryce would argue that no
and I mean he's a big influencer yeah no
big but the biggest no the most famous
influencer 22 years old and has 50
million
followers uh and we have Chris Johnson
who's the coach to the best of the best
in the NBA oh Bryce is a a guest that's
awesome it must be that's exciting can't
wait to watch the Bryce app he like he
teaches LeBron how to get better then
Rabbi Le letter probably the most
influential Rabbi in our uh and our
right now in La maybe in
California if you follow the the rabbi
leagues he's Top Dog in in the whole
state he's number one seed Rabbi dude
this is the number one Rabbi in the
state D D1 Rabbi D absolutely first
draft
pick that's probably the only
interesting part from that excert but
below he talks about you
oh I can't think of another person who
has been involved in more litigation
than you both as a plaintiff and a
defendant and you've been suited for
fraud multiple times why are you such a
magnet for lawsuits oh that's what they
asked him yeah that's a really good
question you've been sued for fraud
multiple times they asked him that
wasn't actually an ask that was a
statement you've been and you've been
sued for fraud multiple times period
statement
then they continue why are you such a
magnet for lawsuits hm why do people
keep why do people keep suing you for
fraud they're trolling and I don't
they're trolling they're theying dud and
for the record um I'm not alleging that
he's done any fraud of any kind just
reading what this interviewer said I
have no evidence and this interview was
where this interview is from a Variety
article huh called Ryan Kavanagh is back
ready to Dish on his
failures Brett Ratner and secret little
tap project oh yeah he's working on a
secret little tap project dude this guy
is like scraping the bottom of the
barrel little Tay what does he want from
Little Tay no but I think nobody in
Showbiz will work with him for anything
if I had the guess that's we working
with L Tay and Bryce Hall
um he said uh the litigation last three
years it sounds like a lot but I just
sued a YouTube blogger i' never heard of
until this but triller the only part
that I was really the Blogger he called
me a blogger he said that in the other
interview we watched M yeah
beta how do you not again I know we said
it but you own a social media company is
he trying to downplay what Ethan's doing
by saying blogger on like that's what my
mom would call but she knows better cuz
she's been around this industry now and
she does her own thing she knows what it
means but calling a blogger that's like
right and she she doesn't she didn't
co-found triller and your mom managed to
figure it out no she's not he he founded
a social media company doesn't know what
a Blog
is uh he says so he goes let's see with
triller the only part that really
actively involved in and still am is the
fight club bare knuckle boxing which is
now the fastest growing combat that
Sport and it has been pirated so the
company triller not me went after people
who they could see as pirates and made
money off the fight yes I'm sure that uh
my unlisted video with 60 views was a
huge um it's the only reason DET it's
the only reason triller didn't work out
yeahh and one of the he's probably going
to try to claim that in Damages and one
of those companies was this professional
troll with like 7 million followers all
he does is attack people that is not
true that's a defamatory he's done now
59 podcasts on me he change that
number's different every time he
mentions it I mean and started a whole
subreddit I did not start a whole
subreddit I don't know where he's
getting the irony man yeah what he's
suing you for and every time he talks I
hear him just make up something he lies
with no um quanti like he doesn't
qualify it yeah like I'm out here being
like alleged with respect I don't know
nothing about nobody mhm but this man is
like he uh he made a Reddit he made a
thousand episodes about me he's outside
my house with a weapon he's running an
Mountain commune of Wikipedia editors
yeah did you hear that yeah holy [__]
that was people were expressing concern
over his well-being because they kind of
could make a good point like he's
talking about a compound of Wikipedia
editors that he sent law enforcement but
they couldn't get to them because
they're so well hidden too much in the
compound right also his eyes were kind
of darting around which I didn't think
much of at the time but a lot of people
point it out might be a symptom some
kind of
alcohol sorosis very interesting
actually good point cuz that's why they
try do that pen pen thing to see if the
eyes are TR looking pretty glassy yeah
yeah yeah feel like it's more than just
him being drunk though that could be
making it worse whatever yeah paranoid
delusions he's suffering from is that
good or bad for my
case he's like an early onset dementia
or something drug induced uh uh dementia
I don't know how much it would directly
impact anything really right well would
it make him like more unhinged or would
he just forget about it I no I guess
we'll find out I will say something that
may saying for your case that he's
bringing up you reading a headline from
briy yet he's lying in variety like this
is just a straight up quote about you
where he's lying in the same publication
he's been lying man it's crazy he's
getting old dude I agree old
dude uh let's
see and this [__] guy that's a
[__] guy so blah blah blah I have 59
podcasts on him I mean that might
actually be true they're not Dad I maybe
I've mentioned him in 59 podcast I mean
easily well he he contradicts himself
did 55 podcast on
me so that's that's a number that's a
number you know he has he has never once
said the same number well it does keep
going up but we haven't talked about him
since before this and I'm like [__] a
long ass time E5 podcast I think he's
just counting every time the background
was of him that he's counting that too
yeah
anyway um he's telling the world that
I'm suing him when actually Siller has
gone after him for piracy I was getting
death threats oh yeah he was getting 20
to 30,000 death threats a minute a day
that was another thing that people are
like that that this is like paranoid
delusions
funny did you pull that Zach I did not
but I will I love that you have now him
saying the URL for the website go ahead
oh it's the best plug
it does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein and he said the website is
funny good right yeah he did yeah he did
compliment it is funny you're right it's
not meant to be funny it's meant to be a
public
service he says I was getting death
threats my ex-wife was getting death
threats my kids were getting death
threats I don't know okay so I sued him
for defamation I won the anti-s slap the
last three years that's the only law
suit that I really had of any substance
when you're in business you're always
going to have Nu since suits and it
happens to be very public triller just
prevailed on two of its cases against
him for piracy bro what the [__] are you
talking about triller did not prevent
Veil against me on
piracy
no these balls Ryan so um
anyway let's get into it let's just jump
right into it right into it failure we
only have an hour really quick oh no
really quick there's two more little
notes this is two hours long well we're
not no we're not I'm kidding go ahead AB
real quick the the first episode is
titled failure 1101 on Apple podcast I'm
guessing he meant to say failure 101
yeah he [__] up the title and in his
bio failure is spelled wrong yep that's
all wait hold on just a small not might
want to go ahe that that you have an
opportunity right now to send him a
message like good luck with your toy
podcast or something like now if
anyone's have a toy podcast it's this
[__] right you know and this
[__] guy this a [__] guy so wait
he misspelled he spelled it f l l i r e
b this [__] is just so even even
types drunk dude yeah he just it doesn't
have time to go back and correct it's
too busy um you guys don't understand
the billionaire lifestyle he's do he's
so dedicated to the failure thing he
really makes an effort to do it in every
facet of his lifeod acting MH all right
go ahead Ryan uh I'm Ryan
[Music]
Kavanaugh featuring this is the the
place where as they say success has many
fathers and failure has none well
failure has found a father and you're
wait wait wait what success has many
fathers but failure has none he's the
father of failure now they have found
their daddy nice he really wanted a
title and he found one daddy
failson love that be here with us also
cam pointed out that the intro sounds
like the PE Hub intro interesting same
colors too
interesting true
and we're very lucky today to have one
of my closest friends one of I'll say
this um I'm going to watch the specific
parts of this video that are interesting
to me that I have commentary on if you
want to watch the whole podcast I
encourage you guys to go visit uh
failure with Ryan kavan Channel and
enjoy his his podcast in its entirety
what I'll be doing is criticism and
critiquing the video so so would you say
that that criticism and critique that
you will be offering this video is um in
some way takes the original video and
transforms it into a new video you may
say that undoubtedly undoubtedly yeah
excellent thank you undoubtedly nobody
who actually wants to watch Ryan
Kavanagh is going to want to watch this
instead absolutely not because there is
zero% Chance [__] out of this dude that
seems fair yeah but goad Ed one I'll be
honest that I have some Theory
because I was like how is this not bait
cuz I'm the only one that's going to
watch this it does seem made for us it's
it's so
dumb it's so
pointless and frankly lowbudget
I'm like he's got to be baiting me so
then it occurred to me that he might
actually be baiting me if he's
copyrighted it beforehand and he's just
he thinks I'm going to watch the whole
two hours of it
and then sue me for copyright
infringement again and be like see
however that's obviously not going to be
an option to him because that's not how
we do content reactions baby we're the
real deal out here that's right so I
mean if you want to sue me I welcome
that as I always
have but yeah here it is sorry I
accidentally closed
it
failure welcome to this is the play and
you're here with us have one of my
closest friends one of uh bro are you
sure you want to be putting that out
there also
why are you shooting directly into a
window this man is a big time producer
he's shooting directly into the sun
anywhere else any was there anywhere
else in the room could set up
failure what an idiot bro like he gets
so cross when people say oh he had this
whole thing Ethan removed that I'm a
producer if you read my Wikipedia page
I'm not a producer well dude you could
start by not shooting into sunlight if
you want to prove that to
us [__] the world's great um producers
the world's great marketers the world's
great showman um and he's uh truly truly
one of the greatest talents I know he's
the one of the main Visionaries he spoke
about Harvey Weinstein similarly I think
before y I think so or was it that
Harvey spoke that way about both Ryan
Ryan kavana is a force of nature now I
do need to go it's just hard to keep him
I remember I remember a clip of Ryan
glazing up Harvey I don't he he kissed
him on the forehead he kissed him on the
head yeah a right on the I don't kiss
anyone on the head but my kids sing
nasty head right American Idol and
produc American Idol nasty pig stinking
neck and the creator of So You Think You
Can Dance Nigel Lithgow welcome Nigel
thank you thank you so happy to be on a
program called
failure you know
what I'm right out of the gate so that's
such a I mean and Ryan I've seen the
beginning he starts floundering like he
doesn't know how to accept the job I
mean you know soon as I thought who
could on failure I thought Nigel right
Nigel failing no but um as we all know
you loser could have laughed I mean it
was pretty funny show is is it's raw
it's meant to show the world the truth
um the truth of success which is uh in
success um this man has
on a recently accused predator on a
failure called on a podcast called
failure where they just do the raw and
talk about it honestly where he doesn't
where he doesn't talk about or
apparently he does say a but I doubt in
a way where he's pursuing any kind of
Truth or right no yeah they just brush
over it yeah I will say that doesn't
happen um he keeps trying to bring back
everything to failure like the guy tries
to tell a story and then he'll go oh so
like yeah so you had a failure and that
led to something this okay okay and then
he stops IT multiple times and the guest
gets annoyed and eventually a few times
he says I hate that word failure but I
just want to give you some context as to
why he seems more frustrated throughout
these uh time stamps oh he seems
frustrated already frankly yeah but you
can move on to the next time stamp
that's all right so the next time stands
at 45 seconds and Nigel says he's H oh
no we saw that one at 11 minutes Nigel
says his first failure was him
attempting to un alive himself when he
was
younger this is this is who what this
you you got it yeah you got you got that
was a failure that was a that was a
failure supp if he it's a hell of a way
to put it that's a little bit weird to
say about an attempt cuz yeah I'm he
makes it sound like he wished he
succeeded this this is one of the best
time stamps not because they un
whoa okay I see I see where it's going
yeah all right go ahead and when I woke
up when my mother had come down from
Liverpool and she was sat next to the
bed as I came to and this beautiful
nurse was on the other side of the bed
leaning over me oh no and I checked out
her breasts shut the [__] up right and I
thought why on Earth did I even think of
committing suicide there's the this guy
did it he did that sh you hear what he
said wait you got to listen you got to
hear
[Music]
I don't want that's all too much I don't
want to you know what I mean huh he said
I didn't want to show all that uh yeah
you're going too far graphic description
of oh oh okay got of the uh yeah so
sorry about that here is the clip uh in
question one more time when I woke up my
mother had come down from Liverpool and
she was sat next to the bed as I came to
and this beautiful nurse was on the
other side of the bed leaning over me uh
and I checked out her
breasts and I thought why on Earth did I
even think of committing suicide there's
the
Nel oh
no yes you knew the whole time there's
the and gentlemen you [__]
Ryan this is so gross on so many levels
imagine saying that to Harvey Weinstein
there's know that old
dog god that's actually not even funny
that's just straight up disturbing yeah
I especially with Ryan knowing the
context of everything go ahead that I
feel like that can be used in a court
just like here's like evidence that he
is like perverse he's like known or not
to it would be a suggestive of
him perhaps allegedly whatever being uh
complicit and covering up a crime yeah I
mean or I don't know if he help cover up
but but being you know remaining silent
in the face of an injustice
yeah argue that I think it's more so
that in like as evidence of character of
the Nigel guy that could be presented as
like look here's one of his good friends
listening to him tell a kind of like a
dirty joke and confirming like oh yeah
he's like this all the time you know
that's crazy that's a wild take this
guy's 74 yeah and the reason he was
happy to be alive is because he saw
boobs yes this was when he was a kid he
was younger this is an old story okay
happen
recently I checked out her breast and uh
I checked out her breasts that's a good
sound
drop and I thought why on Earth did I
even think of committing suicide there's
the [__]
Ryan you scoundrel IDI you dumbass tell
us more what do you
know that's what I always thinking I was
thinking this needs to keep going we
might learn a lot I feel like this could
be very useful he just keeps bringing on
all these people from Hollywood well the
prut might have a reason to subpoena him
now cuz they're like what well I'd like
to know what what do you know Ryan um
definitely if there are any uh
prosecutors cuz there isn't a statute of
limitation on sexual crimes then
definitely Ryan Kavanagh is might know
something yeah that's shocking he might
know something that is shocking holy
[__] this is good [__] that's
nuts wow we might have to add that to
the website like yeah take notes yeah
taking notes yeah but it was it was like
it was you know my mom was in tears also
poor Nigel Ryan had to come bring him on
the first not poor Nigel I'm being
factious but like
you know that like I was going to read
about
him well so I have to imagine because
ryc Dan he's like get a load of this guy
he's way more [__] up than I am maybe
yeah I uh I have to imagine that because
Ryan announced this back in like October
or something last year and said that it
would be coming out in
December uh he said it was going to be
coming out in December and so I think he
has these banked which means he probably
recorded this and then like the next day
the Paul Abdul thing came out which is
definitely that's very Ryan a lot of
times when you start a podcast people
tell you you want to have like at least
three ready before you start uploading
them I don't know why banking content is
the worst thing a podcaster about like
the Audio Apps the podcast apps I these
people are all such Mor they don't
anything yeah like just some Boomer ass
people from an ad agency was trying to
tell us how to do how to do it m I don't
know anything so I had the same thought
as Dan but looking into it I'm seeing
that he was removed in January like
that's when it was publicly announced to
my knowledge that of him being removed
from his show and then last year the
beginning of last year no no this year
okay this year so I'm thinking this like
they did shot yeah and also the
producers that the ones that were
cropped out of that photo they
posted they posted them shooting
together but that was earlier but I
think this one was recent cuz he asks
him again he asks him about being
removed from his own show so oh wow well
that that pretty much says it I mean
unless he knows behind the scenes but
the way it looks is there a way that we
can look at some physical indications of
Ryan and try to match like has he
deteriorated um a measurable amount what
do you mean oh he's falling apart his
eyes are darting all over the place he
did look worse in that one that which
presumably was recorded just this past
week right the conspiracy one yeah he
looked horrible on that one yeah so
maybe this was before that he is wearing
the same watch right it's the white one
as that other podcast remember that was
on the same day though no I'm just
saying that you know yeah if he's
renting the watch or whatever it's doing
all right so um this is uh moving on to
um
1345 Nigel says he knows Ryan as a
failure
because oh oh East German or other
Soviet block dancers so you were
literally choreographing basically 100
people who didn't speak English yeah I
know why you're a failure cuz you keep
getting all of your figures wrong you've
gone from 90 to 100 dude that wasn't
even a joke now he's like I don't like
you bro you don't listen you keep
getting what wrong numbers cuz oh your
figures yeah that was that was ferocious
holy [__] literally choreographing
basically 100 people who didn't speak
English yeah I I know why you're a
failure cuz you keep getting all of your
figures wrong you've gone from 90 to 100
oh it was 90 okay I'm sorry oh my God
math is that my story is my strong suit
CH Ryan you're so oh my God you're so
personal Nigel that's so true I mean we
see that all all of last week now he his
numbers yeah he's not good with math
he's not good with language he's not
good with production frankly what is it
you say you would say you're good at
failure right I got to hear that again
100 why why is it like that there's no
levity in this it's like he just
insulted you and then everybody super
serious like he was making a joke he was
making J choreographing basically 100
people who didn't speak English yeah I I
know why you're a failure cuz you keep
getting all of your figures wrong you've
gone from 90 to 100 oh it was 90 okay
I'm sorry yeah math is not my actually
math is my strong suit what is your
strong suit I actually I
is uh yeah it was it was tough Jesus
Christ
man and like of all the wow somebody in
the chat said Nigel is
Thro Nigel thr oh man dude
Nigel so that was funny we're moving
forward now let's see being surgical
here
Ryan being very surgical with our um our
analysis just making sure that you know
this
would not be a market substitute in any
way for watching the actual failure po I
don't listen I don't think that if we
watch the whole [__] thing I think
it's fair use and wouldn't be Market
substitute my what I'm doing here is
making
it extremely impossible Deb it's not
even debatable it can't even be debated
right yeah everything we do is fair use
though and and just to even clarify that
further our last time stamp was at 13
minutes this one's at 40 minutes yeah
nice try wow what a jump nice try Ryan
send this to your attorney they'll be
like what are you going to how you going
to Sue with this just make you look like
an idiot I welcome it I really do if he
sued me for this I would I would laugh
and the easiest du of them all I I would
have tears of joy and laughter in my
heart so we're moving on to uh 40
minutes Nigel talks about recruiting
people for one of his shows just let it
play I think let it holy [__] okay so he
pulled out so I then up another guy
who's pretty cruel fun but cruel called
Jonathan King did you say fun but cruel
I thought he said cool at first and he
said he said cool no he he said fun but
cool no but why would fun but cool they
don't disqualify each other fun but he's
fun but it again oh sorry you're sorry
cruel yeah he did say Cru that's
psychotic fun crew I got to go back I
need a little more context um said why
on Earth
we chos in a band to give to Universal
yeah it's like the two enemies working
together big time so he pulled out so I
then call up another guy who's pretty
cruel fun but cruel called who's fun but
cruel it's an interesting combination
Hitler I don't think he was that fun I
don't think he was very fun I heard he
was very personable from what I've read
what thought he was a weirdo no he he
was a schmoozer he W he got on well with
like world leaders and stuff before the
war and all that huh I'm pretty sure he
was somewhat
personable [__] weirdo bro probably
had to
be I would have sniffed that guy out
right away how do I how do I how do I
fact check that was Hitler person was
Hitler was Hitler
down was Hitler cool was Hitler was he
cool was he cruel but also fun but also
fun did Hitler pull
up could could Hitler hit it good Hitler
hit oh God all right go on N we love
this about you never Jonathan King H
Nigel's got to be like bro why did I do
this again like can can you back it up
just a little bit I want you to hear the
whole with
pleasure yeah it's like the two enemies
working together big time so he pulled
out so I then call up another guy who's
pretty cruel fun but cruel called
Jonathan King and uh he says yes and
then he's imprisoned oh
no uh as an accused
pedophile that's the cruel part or is
that the fun part the fun part art to
know he was a tough businessman but his
parties were really fun yeah yeah those
parties were fun cruel These Guys these
guys run in a really good crowd man yeah
and he was talking about recruiting
people for one of his shows just to give
the audience some
context
uh
wow these guys are real nasty [__]
pieces of work
here holy [__] man you posted
this real quick chat says Adolf rizzler
That's My Boy cruel but
fun he's a lot of fun you see this by
the
way it's nasty no this is I just he made
a little
peee later in the
video how many times should we label
this as a joke oh yeah this is a joke
this is actually made in Photoshop uh
Ryan Kavanagh this man right here with
the yellow teeth his teeth aren't really
that yellow and he didn't piss his pants
it looks clear this is fake it looks so
good though how could it be photoshopped
I know it's unbelievable but he did not
in fact urinate I'm going to need a
judge to make a call on that you know
what I think he happened I think his
diaper overfill build sometimes that
happens you might think that however
it's it's Photoshop oh okay I thought
Nigel scared him go on Nigel tell me
more about your pedophile
friend um so I'm now stuck with a week
to go H and we can move on oh my God let
me just see Ryan's reaction to that one
more time cruel fun but cruel called
Jonathan King and
can you look up Jonathan King is he in
prison like he I did yeah and this
happened back in like 2001 this is a
long I looked it up the other day so
what happened to our cruel but fun
Legend Jonathan King the accused
pedophile uh yeah God he just looks it
too yeah yeah godamn I mean oh no
no no oh
no I mean anybody you know it could be
anybody but I mean come on y oh
no so was he whated his uh career in the
music industry is effectively ended in
2001 when he was convicted of sexually
abusing five teenage boys oh wait why do
you say accused then sounds like he's
convicted why would he say accused
you're running defense for a pedophile
still no I think he says he went to
prison oh he does let me listen cuz he
say he sold him out he he says yes and
then he's imprisoned yeah oh he went to
prison yeah about as an accused
pedophile no but he says accused he does
say accused you can go to prison while
you're waiting for he's not accused he's
convicted that man is convicted
pedophile good catch they were just
trolls that is a good catch those little
kids were trolls chess says nul's like
[__] it no one will watch this I know
right that's what I think too bro what
do you mean alleged so let's see here's
the full the full he was convicted of
child sexual abuse and seven sentenced
to seven years in prison for sexually
assaulted five boys age 14 and 15 in the
1980s in November 2001 he was acquitted
of 22 similar charges okay so he got
convicted on five but was acquitted on
22 more oh can I say damn that essaying
five little boys and he got seven years
that's really light it's got to go for
life like people who steal snicker bars
go to jail for more time than that all
right seven years um this was uh in the
UK it looks like get out and do it he
will do that's the thing he'll get out
and do it again yes like this man is not
safe to be in society sure let me see
wait was it only four years it says he
was oh you're saying when he was
recharged because it says he was
released on parole in 2005 well he was
released on parole early I mean that
happens he was originally sentenced to
seven years he got out after four okay
got good
behavior he he didn't rape any kids yeah
no little boys in prison did he tweet
this what is it what I said he did I
don't know if this man's walking around
with the balls to [__] hold
on don't know I got a image that Ela got
king of hits is this real I don't know
oh it might not be Jonathan King oh it
might be him spring
day this guy I that's him right I mean
you could that looks like him so he
posted this with one like in 2020 this
[__] who's R worded kids is walk
cruising around saying spring day you
should be in jail still dude his bio say
ex pop star TV person minor celebrity
filmmaker and target of trolls but
aren't we all the way he used minor he's
just trolled poor guy look at um look at
what cam just picked up on in his
Wikipedia article King was arrested in
November and bailed for wait he actually
says trolls you're not kidding no I'm
not K this is his
description X pop star TV person minor
celebrity see I don't like what he says
minor yeah that's celebrity right cuz
miners is what you know it's his type he
uh he did write some hits though
man what did he write he wrote uh hooked
on a feeling you know ah I can't listen
to that anymore Hooked On
A now that I know it's about
our can't believe that he's actually
calling the little boy trolls like I
thought I was making such a horrible
joke just because of like Ryan that's
what he calls everybody he said
filmmaker and target of trolls but
aren't we all so true he doesn't go as
far as to say my accusers are trolls
this Twitter account is 14 years years
what years old he's like let me put to
include he's like let me put it this way
this Twitter account is so old I don't
even want to [__]
[Laughter]
it um um you will want to hear this
little detail that cam found though what
go ahead cam or Dan uh well King was
arrested in November uh he bailed
150,000 50,000 of which was put up by
Simon Cowell oh
[Laughter]
Jesus why no why cruel but look at this
bro Jonathan King is tweeting defense
for R Kelly wow oh wow he goes R Kelly
disgraced he's not disgraced at all
innocent unless and until proven guilty
oh well he was so what a sick [__] of a
human being he's as much as media FS
over false accusers but it's a good
story with lots of money in it what well
this was in 2019 maybe he's updated his
stance since you know he was he was
convicted right he's also writing for
Michael
Jackson is he he for Michael Jackson
sorry AB if there's any proof that
Michael
did I was I wasn't listening but I just
know that Michael Jackson was trolled a
lot yeah it's just a bunch of trolls no
what happened um what did he say about
Michael Jackson he says # MJ
innocent wait
where dude this guy's a legend my God he
he's a pedophile Advocate somebody's got
a advocate for them yeah everybody needs
an
advocate he's taking up he's taking up
the mantle that nobody else would was
brave enough toh take many who report
Neverland will be horrified by this it
reveals that there are millions of false
accusers and those who like to hear only
negative claims MJ innocent points out
the dozens of Jackson Defenders not
shown in the Gastly dock right but it's
not about the people defending him it's
about the people that accused him the
people that defending him clearly
wouldn't know about his crimes or they
wouldn't be defending him
probably sorry AB he did that [__] after
reading this you I have to keep saying
sorry I'm not I'm not writing for him
I'm not saying anything no I know I know
I know I'm just saying I think I think
if I'm talking to anybody who thinks
MJ's innocent this seals the deal I just
went to Neverland I didn't say [__] I
don't bring that up that still hurts
yeah you don't get to complain about me
jok after that I got to say I have a
hole in my heart watching that I Eli I
could have gone on for an hour if you
weren't here I just felt bad but I would
have been fine it was funny I mean you
guys call out fake stuff for a living so
I was just like man the fact that you
guys were so I wanted to believe I
wanted to believe
yeah oh
god um Joe Rogan was on Alex Jones what
the
[__] huh how did we get here I just saw
his name trending so I clicked it Al Joe
Rogan went on Alex
Jones that's
crazy that's crazy isn't that just
darling just scrolling through all his
tweets he's just speedrun running saying
that everyone is innocent like every
known p word is in W actually if you ask
him I don't think I think essay is a
myth I don't think um I don't think
anybody ever has done that ever
never all right so anyway shout out to
Nigel for keeping the great company he
says alleged uh Predator not convicted
all right um moving on Ryan keeps
interrupting the guests to bring up the
word failure this sounds great this is
why I'm here this is why I'm watching
stole people's hearts oh no I don't know
if I should tell you this Jason Nash is
live again he's always live yeah he's
always live
yeah that's always been
true the whole thing was find out about
the people back story because you find
the back story this goes back to the
failure them the same as we did with pop
stars care about them see them getting
drunk
see them say no I didn't have anything
to drink show them drinking this whole
thing was about people whole thing was
about people and the same with pop Idol
now and that takes us back to your
original failure is had you not gone
through that you never would be at this
place where you're like this show is
only going to work this is the whole
interview nobody cares bro the whole
interview Ryan's interrupting failure so
that's a failure and but but it brought
you to where you're at today I mean
listen I'm sure this guy has lots of
interesting stories you don't have to do
the whole failure stick
buddy work it's about people about
people cuz that's what you didn't do the
first time correct and that's where the
failure comes full circle bro shut up we
get it it's like a bit how he's harping
on you we get it that's the name of the
podcast you get it you get it that's the
concept oh [__]
absolutely and now we've got these two
people um is that it yeah very good love
that well done Ryan moving on Nigel says
he hates the word failure uhoh
H Ryan that sounds awkward and should
never you should never even class I hate
the word failure
uh no it's you hate our podcast it's a
well yeah I mean it's pretty obvious
stupid word because you're not failing
you you you haven't been successful not
being successful is not failing failing
is when you do something terrible or you
I'm going to step in here Ryan has
definitely
failed you skipped one you go to G oh I
did yeah Ryan asked Nigel why he is not
on So You Think You Can Dance anymore
should I watch more of this did I miss
something no that's pretty much give up
that's fa that's
awesome uh that's a really good question
Ryan why do you think Ryan is wearing
like sweatsuits when it's stole people's
H guest is like a well-known producer
cuz he's a failure he thinks in his mind
this is his way into the the internet
world and he's going to be hip that's
why he's wearing those hype be shoes
last time too I
think true he's wearing like $50,000
shoes or some [__] yeah that Zach
pointed out yeah in this video no in the
last time that you guys were watching no
in the pool side remember the yellow
lobsters yeah those are those are not
cheap hopefully someone steps on him oh
I hope he creases the [__] not on
purpose I mean on accident like somebody
passing by you know people step on your
foot yeah it happened or gum you know
gum that would be killer dog [__]
yeah and remember my whole thing was
find out about the people back story
because you the back story G you went
back to G the one under that didn't you
say G yeah g that wasn't G that was
F all right G
and so sure enough So You Think You Can
Dance was Bor uh and again thank
goodness
successful it's just going into season
18 as we speak
now um unfortunately my failure is they
no longer want me as a judge he brought
it up mhm on my own
program failed that happened last year
so oh Ryan's like oh
[__] oh going back to the beginning of
any research did he gloss over it just
yeah that's it that's it holy sh what a
what a fraud wow I knew that'd be a good
one I love that keemstar sound bite do
it again y oh my
God wait Ryan really he goes why did
that happen and then he remembers and
he's like moving on he's like
oh right whoa dude you are such a
hack it's almost like your hobby at this
point covering for
or N I won't I won't go that far n
that's just a that's just a a stupid
joke I don't believe he covers any he
covers for any crimes he would never do
you know who's replacing
Nigel yeah who JoJo
siwa no way yikes what as a as a judge
yeah I mean she probably has more
relevant comments than him though his
old ass yeah yikes is they no longer
want me as a judge on my own program
when did that that happened last year so
going back to no followup oh wow it
happened last year tell me about that
there may have been a hard cut there
wait that's that's the that's the proof
right there that he shot this recently
actually cuz it this is January happened
in December yeah so Ryan knows let's see
the the first round Paul Abdul's
accusations were in December but there
was there was two others are we sure
that those no I saw that Paula Abdul's
came like two weeks after
the other ones yeah I remember reading
that I'll dou can you find the date it
was published so we can know for sure
Nigel I'm curious if you can see there's
a hard cut if they move a lot that's
what I want to right now yeah thank
goodness successful uh and it's just
going into season 18 as we speak
now um unfortunate but if they're going
to cut it cut it here cut you know what
I mean don't right cut it right here
yeah before he brings that up do season
18 as we speak
now um
unfortunately my failure is they no
longer want me as a judge on my own
program failed that happened last
year I it doesn't seem like there's a
cut but let's let's
compare yeah this shot seems pretty the
thing is we got to compare [__] happened
last year let's look closer my own
program so so and is in the same
yeah there's no cut no there's no cut he
just brushed past it okay he's like yeah
so I got fired for uh committing really
crazy crimes and all this CRA he's like
so anyway tell me about uh project yeah
what else you working on buddy
nice that happened last year so going
back to the beginning of
this you're at the top of the world you
go through a life-changing event you're
evaluating everything and is he talking
about the
accusations yeah I guess kind of in
vague terms you come out of the
reevaluation um you know Health scare a
life scare
and but you get stronger from that you
come out and you take what most would
argue you can't get more success than
this and you actually create more
success bro he's at probably at the
lowest point in his life right now yeah
like why are you dude you missing the
mark so hard okay so the Paula Abdul was
in December of 2023 and then the other
girls the two other contestants were
days
after so he knew about all this most
likely sounds like it it was last year
yeah it sounds like it the way that he
glazed over it was pretty
telling cuz even like the most like
amateur interviewer would be like oh
tell me about that that sounds crazy now
he could have it is it's not likely I
mean it's possible he knew about it a
little bit sooner maybe before it was
public but it all seemed to happen
within like a week's time though so I
mean regardless this was Ryan definitely
knew unless he did no research can't say
definitely we can't say definitely Ian
it's possible he did no research on his
guest it's a well that sure that shows
definitely but they're supposed close
friends supposedly well based on the
fact that he glossed over it B based on
the fact that they're close friends
based on the fact that Ryan's in this
industry and presumably did research on
his guest I think it's a safe bet to
assume make an educated assumption that
he know about all of that [__] well
agree Yeah well yeah them him being
removed from the show and also in the
article the interview about it he said
he's going through a hard time so I love
he doesn't ask he blew it well here
let's see where he's going with So You
Think You Can Dance and um and you
changed dancing for the whole world cuz
as he said prior to that oh yeah he went
back he's like yeah
mhm nice Ryan you really have a
future oh wait this is so epic I so hold
on we did um the failure one we did uh
he asked why he's not on so dance he
hates the word failure here Ryan tries
to call Edison a failure Thomas Edison
it in 100 Thomas Edison the famous
failure big
loser [__] dumb ass I'm sure he
failed at some things in his life
probably I think it was Einstein not
Edison who who we talked about this last
time he had a very famous last time Al
so this isn't even his first one they
did it out of order talked about this
last time he says we and last time a lot
I don't know I who it's like Trump it's
just
very everyone's saying it I'll mess up
on the numbers but it was something like
when he he finally invented the light
bulb and he' spent years TR to doing
they said how does it feel to invent the
light bul he said I didn't invent the
light bulb I just showed you 99,999 ways
not to do it yeah did he say that is
that a real thing yeah there is let me
find out who exactly said it how it was
said but yeah I know just like Ryan
literally spent he had the exact number
down too I think it was like
9,876 ways not to do right but in his
mind he was saying I did fail I just
failed 986
9,876 times now he's succeeded did right
but I think he's like trying to make a
point I love how he's pushing it back
like he's like listen the concept needs
work but
it oh I think the difference in human oh
my God they're really going to argue
about this do you give up or do you not
give yeah the quote is kind of the quote
is not at all what he's characterizing
as I'm seeing I'm seeing two different
quotes cuz I saw what you saw Dan you
you're talking about the I didn't fail a
thousand times a light bulb was an
invention with a thousand steps yes yes
that's that so Ryan has repurposed that
quote to fit his own agenda well I'm
also seeing I haven't failed I have just
found 10,000 ways that won't work okay
he said I haven't fail he started it
with that right either way Ryan you got
to you got to reink B this whole thing
Ryan was honing in on on he gave like a
specific number I don't see that
anywhere it it's a thousand times it's
it's a nice round number I get the
feeling Ryan made a
9,800 whatever very specific number
started with 9,000 he remembers cuz
that's how many death threats he was
getting every
hour how could he forget he just making
up yeah it was 1.21
gigawatts well Nigel's right then cuz
actually Nigel proved himself to be more
uh wise cuz he's like that's not failure
and if you go back to original oh Edison
clearly agrees yeah yeah he
agrees what an idiot so maybe Ryan
should if he understands that he's bad
with numbers maybe he should avoid
listing exact numbers or being a
financer right that is kind of like his
his thing
supposedly his
numbers well that yeah he had his big
thing was he had this algorithm that he
said I can prove mathematically that
certain movies will be money makers and
other ones and him being the math genius
he is his business went bankrupt
crushed so but that's not even the epic
part about this conversation is that he
keeps trying to argue that Edison is a
failure and other guy's like how is he a
failure I want to listen actually I want
to listen and that's the question if if
he'd have given up yep we'd have never
have had the light bulb right and he
would have failed right he didn't fail
well I guess it comes a question of what
point he failed and failed and failed
but never stopped failing till he
succeeded yeah that's why I just said do
you really think that that's an
interesting point to to try to argue
look how dumb he is look at his
face what a
[__]
G
A
Ryan he's like tomato tomato
whatever that's what way I look at it
okay I look at it that he didn't
fail they
both they both won't let it go it's
actually interesting like that's really
cool it's a it's a you know that we one
and the same thing so so let me ask you
so it's a totally
different we're saying the opposite dude
Nigel's amazing for this I love his
dedication to find it that Nigel is
actually more correct in the way that
that quote was in reality like it's way
closer to what Nigel is saying well
despite him being an accused Predator he
was actually unlike Ryan successful and
seemingly a smart guy yeah cruel but fun
one might say he's cruel but fun yeah so
he's talking to like a real Showbiz
success and he's obviously a total
fraud so you can see the difference here
latitude well Ryan's like no my life is
all failure failure failure failure
their failure mhm he's like no no no
well Edison's not a failure cuz he made
the light bulb and then Ryan's like [__]
[__] maybe I'm just the failure not
everyone else just me you're kind of
right because shortly after he's like
yeah you know we were thinking about
naming this something else oh God oh God
he's so first episode oh my God they're
bailing on the first episode to me I
think the reason we using the word
failure is and the reason we focus on
failure is a lot of people are just so
disheartened with the world today right
and it's so everything's all about
Instagram and look how pretty this
person is and all the influencers are so
amazing and you know oh that's you
you're describing yourself yeah that's
literally your life yeah this is the
most surface level like
dumbass podcast conversation ever like
he's so
uninteresting it's painful everything's
great and look everybody's life is
perfect like I'm sure you know who would
be a great host for this Brad the
bull yeah should come sub
in the bull should come Sub in for him
he's no Ryan's a sub
actually nice on the show most people
assume oh you know Nigel he's British
and that dress as well and did an
American Idol and So You Think You Can
Dance and what a privileged guy who just
had tons of success right and now hear
they're like wow he you know what he's
you know what he's doing he he's what
he's doing is saying that um people look
at me like a NEPA baby but what they
don't know is that I
actually worked and earned this stuff
all by myself right I got a small loan
of a million dollars that was it yeah I
made a whole Film Production Studio at
25 like you
do but also just real quick to add to
Ryan's you know they look at you and say
you're British you dress well he forgot
to say they look at him and say oh he's
accused of sexual assault multiple times
I think that's what more people are
seeing as they're watching this that's
rough yeah that's definitely rough these
trials and tribulations and most people
don't have that that stamina to just not
give up and not give in right and and
just fight through it and I I disagree I
think people are Fighters and they and
all look failure success doesn't mean
like becoming a millionaire all the time
or making some groundbreaking invention
or whatever the [__] you do on a
day-to-day basis I mean success can mean
a lot of things and I think people in
general do push and work hard towards
things that are important to them every
day all the time you're not special in
fact raising kids alone is like the
hardest thing in the world like you're
the outlier bro you're the one that
failed we're all doing
great it's just
you I
think part of this is for those people
who are just at that Brink where they're
about to give up and they feel like
they're a failure they haven't fail but
they feel like they're a failure they've
been told they're a failure so he's
walking it back now he's talking to
himself we can move on to the next time
stamp because we're running out of time
we got 355 that's so good all right
we're moving on to um Nigel asks Ryan if
he is a failure good
question failure let me ask you a
question yeah straight question ran
kavar are you a
failure no I am not a failure
I have proof to the
contrary I wish you would have kept
going I feel like this could have been
one of those Robin Williams it's not
your fault moments you would just kept
digging a little
more but I have fa have you been
unsuccessful yes but I've also failed a
million times wait you just said yes but
also I failed what so what we say is
Nigel's like this guy's full of [__]
yep God
success has many fathers and failure has
none and this show is a place where
failure has a father I'm here we we have
success as many parents failure as an
orphan is what so he
[Laughter]
corrected what's this saying success has
many parents parents and failur failure
orphan why because nobody wants to own
failure yeah that makes more sense than
the way what how did Ryan say it success
has many fathers and failure has none
and
it was John Kennedy who said success has
many fathers but failure is an orphan
this was my ass what he has a knack for
like taking quotes and making them dumb
as
[__] oh that's that's a good talent the
show is a place where failure has a
father and I'm here we we have success
as many parents failure as an orphan is
well in here what the whole point of
failure our show is people Nigel's kind
of a legend for the way he's just
thrashing Ryan all this whole episode he
is also an accused Predator but I I
hedge my state my compliments with uh
with that as a home but to show people
that they're not to the final all right
and then moving
on we have uh Nigel asks Nigel says he
hates the word failure again uh
oh the argument continues failure
is
um just a bad
word yeah I just dislike the word
failure love this
podcast hate the word failure it's okay
listen that's part of what we're here
for is to yeah Embrace SL haate I mean
it when I say it it's embraced the fact
that you're going to trip and trip call
it can you just let him talk you already
said it like so many times God he's so
bad I love how he looks like he's
looking out the window to look at the
word failure again like oh [__] maybe
shouldn't have had that in the
background should I um I can offer to
give him a master class I can do a
podcast master class for
him that'd be cool I'd do
that I'd do it let's strike a deal Let's
Make a Deal Ryan you certainly could use
any
advice failure or say I'll come over to
your studio and we'll uh we'll turn the
camera the other direction so it's not
directly into the window I'll hook you
up 101 baby yep you know 101 11
101 but whatever you call you're always
going to fail right you're always GNA be
but you're not a failure you're always
going to be unsuccessful y but you do
not have to be a failure you think we
should change that we were originally
going to call it dare to fail no no
that's no shut up that is actually a
worse title even even dare to fail dude
Nigel is [__] hates Ryan I think we
should change we were originally going
to call it dare to fail no no no no
yeah failure is perfect just deny it
yeah and deny it in yourself here's
where all deny it
is there there's so many points in my
life are you a failure now no but
there's so many points where I thought I
we can definitely debate that sounds
like you think you are yeah there's
doubts there are doubts well point to
one thing you're succeeding at let's
start there I thought you said you're
the father or failure right too like the
choose a lane he's the god of failure
it it's kind of Epic though that he's
being [__] on by Nigel because he is a
piece of [__] but from what I understand
from this interview he is responsible
for some of like most famous television
shows like American Idol he's the real
deal and frankly seeing them sit next to
each other and talk you can tell that
Ryan's a total impostor and this guy
knows what he's talking about what do
you mean he he founded Marvel Studios
true I
forgot I was if you ask Ghost Rider true
points I'd say yes right now a failure
but now right now so you would have been
wrong you're right right right that's
the point is just move on man I didn't
fail life gave me that cuz I needed it
to get to the next step of where I was
going to be I never knew what that was
going to be I think that's the most
important thing and the
best you give to anybody is that there
are other avenues it's because you've
been unsuccessful at
this one thing doesn't mean you're going
to be unsuccessful at that so is he
going to have this conversation every
episode yep I'm so curious to see if he
tries to interject the word failure as
much in the next episode we'll see
hopefully someone told him he got to
chill with that but who knows so that's
our
boy um very exciting um I look forward
to the second episode frankly can't wait
but uh he really here how the Bryce one
goes listen as a friend and a fan of
Bryce I look forward to that I think
Bryce is will probably be a good
interviewee
um but I I definitely look forward and I
mean as first as as far as first podcast
episodes go I think having Nigel on in
the wake of this scandalous
accusations um was a really interesting
step and brushing right over it brushing
it actually and then saying that's the
Nigel I know let's not forget that here
let me open that one more time CU that
was my favorite part that I think was
the was the um yeah the big moment of
the show for me yeah let's take a look I
really wish he had started rambling with
this Nigel guy about when I woke
Wikipedia editor Comm he wanted to he
did he wanted to it's like how much do
you know about Wikipedia Nigel it'll
come up my mother had come down from
Liverpool and she was sat next to the
bed as I came to and this beautiful
nurse was on the other side of the bed
leaning over me uh and I checked out her
breasts and I thought what the way he
said it with like not a hint of sarcasm
is really creepy mhm yeah and the fact
that he wasn't like yo cut that cut that
[__] I said about bre being a creep he
didn't hesitate even a little bit it was
just like and of course obviously I
checked out the nurse's breasts didn't
smile he also says mother is sobbing to
to my to the side of my bed and I'm
checking out this nurse's
breast
awesome did I even think of committing
suicide there's the Nigel in it but it
was Nigel's like you don't know
me right like [__] yeah dude wait that
was I mean that was a really crazy
comment that's such a bad comment
considering the timing of everything
that's happening even even not it's not
something you want to say
about like it makes Nigel look like a
freak yeah and it makes Ryan look like
he's
covering it's horrible I mean that's
just the worst thing you could could say
probably like if you went in a lab and
you're like let's think of the most
damaging thing I can say about both of
us I think you would I think the AI
would crunch the numbers and say there's
the Nigel I
know well well done Ryan we're all very
excited for
you very excited very happy maybe what
we should do um is do a write up summary
review yeah of the first episode m put
it on our website y absolutely I was
thinking the same we'll embed the video
so we'll get like video search it's for
him we'll embed the YouTube link yeah
well and our review of it yeah just such
a good informational article there and
so yeah um well that's really good
because we even if we watch the first
video we can see it's called Uh episode
one with Nigel litho that's great yeah
I'm excited yeah that's exciting
good all right listen I got to run it's
four you got a 2-year-old to go
celebrate I want to go be with our
birthday boy that went by so fast I mean
God we probably doing yeah just about a
three- hour show oh
really that was a fast three hours I say
bye bye having fun over
here well everyone have a great weekend
love to see
you hate to see you
that's what Nigel says when his Nanny
walked out the door every
time that
scoundrel um have a great weekend
everybody it's been a great fun week of
shows and we'll have another great fun
week uh next week so have a great
weekend and we'll see yall on
Monday
[Music]
t my
own